foreign
by a good friend of ours a hilarious
comic he's got a new Netflix special out
now give it a watch thank you oh good
buddy uh Jared freed great to be here
this is such a pleasure you're you're a
real uh you're a real New York City
Drinker New York City Drinker yeah I
don't that reputation like you get
afraid of that like you don't want to be
like he's a New York City Drinker you
know like don't want I
have a fun reputation you know because
I'm not like I'm a drinker and then like
go home eat right like that's my move is
drunk eating is like I mean like it's
sad like if I told you what I order like
I could read you my order oh you know it
was a diner or a Taco Bell that that's a
big question I will read you my order
okay yeah there's the type of guy that
if you go and drink with every time you
turn around he hands you another thing
yes right I I like them keep them coming
we're out let's have fun I'm really into
martinis these days which is like a bad
I can't we just had a bunch of Montreal
uh dirty's yeah the dirty vodka
Frozen they did the frozen ones yes we
we uh there's a line in back to school
you know Dangerfield goes uh bring us a
picture of beer every seven minutes
until someone passes out then bring us
one every 10. and that's that is going
out with Jerry yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
I'd like to have a good time I mean like
that's like you know I you know I I
think that's like the whole thing like
we do such a stupid fun thing why
wouldn't I go out here's my here's my
late night eating order okay this is sad
I can't wait okay ready one chicken
salad sandwich whole wheat everything
bagel toasted lettuce red onion fresh
jalapeno add American cheese that's a
great that's a great great sandwich on
its own yeah I got three more coming oh
this is
four sandwiches one bacon egg and cheese
on an everything bagel whole wheat
staying up Bodega or like a deli this is
like a deli Bodega yeah yeah one egg
salad I am like just looking to fart for
the next week one egg salad sandwich
toasted lettuce tomato red onion one
bagel with lox cream cheese uh
everything bagel toast with scallion
cheese like that's like I can't
Jewish order and it's a pretty chewy
order yeah chicken salad the the smoked
salmon yeah steak nugget cheese salad
egg salad soup late night do you get a
bottle of manishevitz as well yeah with
it anytime you order any salad sandwich
just feels chewy yeah a little bit but
they're all great I love them big fan oh
yeah wait a minute so wait
this is what's great about Jared first
of all you're a Dying Breed thank you
okay no one's drinking anymore and then
the comedy business everybody's sober
and healthy and wellness and all this
mental trauma give me a
cocktail you queef squit your belly
aching we're drinking the drink of the
summer right now is the Miller uh
spaghett spaghett yeah so it was uh made
by this guy uh Cahill in Baltimore in
like 2016. and it's the summary Drake is
basically like uh I don't know like the
trash bag aperol Spritz uh all right
Miller High Life the champagne of beers
a little bit of April and lemon is there
lemon juice in it there's lemon juice in
it but you can just throw it out and
it's gonna Fizz up a little bit you guys
are like the Andy Cohen yeah alcoholics
like this is the bar I love has it been
said a million times no never this is
the Bravo Clubhouse yeah hell yeah
we're doing the housewives after you
um
I like wow that's delightful love this
what do you call it
um who needs a name oh that's called the
the spaghetti apparently the spaghetti
it comes from like the Tim and Eric show
or something like that um it's like some
reference I don't know what the
reference is too it's sweet enough I
like a sweet beer I like when there's a
flavored beer I love a lemon people have
been doing that with Coronas for ages
you know they put a little grenadine and
a little lime in there and that's like
that they've been doing that forever and
I guess this is just like the Baltimore
version of that but it blew up online
and recently yeah it's like a summer
drink the snake bite yeah yeah yeah I
know what's a snake bite it was a very
English thing like a European it's like
I think there's like it's like a like a
cherry juice or or something like that
uh in like a light lager this is yeah
this is a problem I could have 30 of
these I was just literally when you said
I was going I could have 30. yeah like I
could literally sound easy too
easy well I was taking over when I
walked in me too I mean I got 10 more
and then we got another drink after this
though so don't worry well you gotta
help those hangers with the 17
sandwiches you're wolfing down like
Jared over here I go through them I I
have a late night eating Pro I I mean
half of the special is me talking about
late night yeah and drunk eating and
watching African right sorry yeah the uh
the Hot Pockets of late night eating so
I I yeah I just uh I can't I get in this
Zone where it's like yeah I don't know
about you but like before bed you're
like the day's over the eating's over I
get like a little bit sad and I'm like I
need to end this with something to like
I would love video footage of you
house at your apartment with the four
sandwiches I'm picturing shirt off oh my
God using like the bed sheet is a napkin
you got uh The Bachelorette on just
going to town you actually nailed it
sure at all yeah that's me this is me
I'm the David Hasselhoff drunk what a
bull I think of this all the time it's
in pretty good shape actually oh he's
getting great off man yeah yeah but this
is me this is closer to me than I'd like
to admit oh spitting It Up Is this where
he calls his daughter a pig or whatever
is that I think that was Alex Baldwin
sorry or maybe Pat O'Brien I'm thinking
that was another bad drunk uh episode
what happened to that guy he got
hammered and he basically got canceled
because he killed Hollywood right right
he was a mess but a fun guy that's the
thing about like you know when someone
says oh Jared's the drink I don't you
know you go that's you know you go okay
good good drink you know like he goes
your only good energy right I I that's
what I like I've always uh enjoyed like
going out especially like after a show
you got that high it's like the best
right and but you need a good like show
post show situation I think it can go
badly like never a chair too loud like
we're always late night yeah you know I
hate too loud I'm with you this is
what's great about you you should live
on the Upper West Harlem me kind of I
was in Harlem yeah yeah and then uh you
know did your pod I'd see you whatever I
randomly bump into you in the in the in
Greenwich Village my neighborhood and I
was like what are you doing here like I
moved here yeah and you just started
rattling off the spots to go you're like
I Love This Bar that restaurant's
amazing I've lived there for six years I
didn't half of these places I've done a
lot of investigation and like also like
the audience that I you know that seems
to follow me most it's like young women
with lists
[Music]
that's a big thing with women they all
have lists of icks they have lists of
bars they like they love list like
itemize my brother's pretty good about
it but it's a very female it is like to
be like these are the bars I hope to be
taken to one day on a date you're like
you're right we can all dream I guess
yeah every girl growing up had like the
hot guy list or like the pictures of
this is the hottest guy than him than
him yeah you're right they rank they
love rank love a ranking love a I have
these are my bars and restaurants I'm
gonna go to so I get a lot of like I get
a lot of like suggestions yeah so like
and it's always a little more refined a
little more like you know we go drink
you know we drink these things in an
alley we'd be like this will be fine
enough for us like young women they're
like I want to be
seated yeah with my friends and be able
to talk and I'm like I kind of fit that
too that's what I like you know there's
something fun though about like I'm with
you I'll drink anywhere in this right
during the pandemic that was a fun thing
is like you really could kind of drink
in the street yeah oh that's I mean when
those when the streets like had the
tables and everything out I loved it I
was like and then people would be like
how's New York and I'm like it's
the Roaring 20s out here it's great what
are you talking about instead of stands
on Sixth Avenue like aperol stands it
was great yeah there was a bar near me
on the Lower East Side when I lived
there during the pandemic and they'd
open a window like it was The Wizard of
Oz you know they'd open a window and I
would go up to it every day I used to
pass by just to check it out four
o'clock and they'd have the regular I
think it's called it's Iggy's or
something and it was on uh I lived on
Ludlow it was on Ludlow and like I would
like just like I'm like are there people
out there let me look and I went up to
the window one day and I was like hey I
I see you guys are open up they're like
we thought you were a cop no like
forever like they thought I was
undercover like trying to shut them down
I was like no I'm here to party let's
do it they gave you a bag with
like the chips because they have the
food yeah the food that's right yeah
yeah and also they were very LAX on
drinking Outdoors during the pandemic
you could just
like we got to serve we got to make sure
we're giving food too and you're like oh
thanks for the a bag of UTS yeah this is
a really good meal right I've always and
then you go ah it's not so bad I'm happy
I had some Hudson yeah oh we were just
in Canada Norman and I and in the
dressing room they have the Ruffles all
dressed it's my number one potato chip
they do ketchup or what do you catch up
too it's ketchup barbecue sauce sour
cream and onion and salt and vinegar
that's the flavor it's a lot coming at
you but God damn they it's good they
just do it better I mean Canada like
when you go to Europe and you see these
like just the foods like the snacks like
you there's thought put in I feel like
like here's garbage and right it's the
everything bagel of chips all dressed I
love that I love it that is very nice
that's a ruffle underrated chips
the ridge a built-in crunch for your
pleasure and strong strong enough for a
onion yeah right I can hold the weight
yeah it's not too soft not too hard
right
what's your what's your cocktails like
your top go-to orders I know you do
vodka soda sometimes but if you're like
a cool bar I I'm really in a dirty
martini right now like I'm like down
that road so hard so it would go
dirty vodka martini with like as cold as
it can humanly be yes I would go
casamigos on the Rocks lime that's
another route uh vodka soda I've kind of
gotten away from just because I'm like
looking to slow down here's my other
drink that I picked up during the
pandemic was from my mom flavored vodka
on the Rocks so I'd be having absolute
Citron on the Rocks that's my that's
that's a and my mom would be like come
in let's have a drink wow and my mom
would get like have ruby red but yeah
always absolute that's like not too
sweet yeah absolute flavored on the Rock
slime boy your mom parties she's
drinking vodka straight chilling having
a great time my parents we were in Boca
you're bokeh I know what do you think a
lady would want a splash of agua or
something or a Diet Coke we're getting
after it my dad doesn't drink at all so
he's just like watching us oh what
happened he's hasn't drank since he's
been like 40. yeah man he doesn't like
it he had a heart attack like real young
so like he was I think that was like you
know yeah
he's doing it right yeah my dad is
pretty Square wears a suit every day you
know he drinks a a glass of wine every
now and then I'm like man what happened
what what is this does it skip a
generation and he goes yeah my dad
before me died when I was two he was
drunk driving he was womanizing he was
smoking so I was like hey that's where I
got it
my mom's side is like not at all and
then uh yeah she would you know I
remember like having two beers in
college at dinner with my grandpa and he
was like he ordered two beers and I was
like yeah I drink ready
when you're not here
this is my pregame but then uh but then
you know I find out like stories about
when I met my biological father he's
like oh yeah you're he's like my mom and
dad were like alcoholics I was like
there we go there we go see my family
was in the liquor business for a long
time so we almost had like everyone kind
of had the mentality of like a dealer
like don't get high in your own Supply
but people you know we drank but like
but the whole family like in my garage
was literally I would walk out and take
a handful of nips on my way out to go
out in high school like I would just
take a handful of those airplane vodkas
oh yeah and it was all like the weird
because you get all the testers right so
it'll be like banana flavor yeah
all that Goldschlager right as a
kid remember doing that real like a
remember peppermint schnapps and Hershey
syrup and you shake it up and you like a
Peppermint Patty oh I never did that one
nasty but we would do we try to get
creative with these things
I would love it if he was in the middle
of making that exact thing he doesn't
make he makes good yeah I have
Goldschlager and peppermint vodka right
here this this is a problem this is this
is good I totally agree the way you guys
go don't worry I only have 10 more of
them so it's okay well I'm not a big
beer is not my go-to order I just I I
factor in the amount of peas and like I
I'm more of a whiskey Peas I just pee
way more money
and also just like the amount of beers
it takes you to like feel anything I
mean maybe I'm maybe no it's a lot but
like for me it's like I'm just bloated
like it's just a lot of beer like I'll
have a beer at the end of the night to
like yeah that's nice polish it off like
that's the finisher but yeah well I just
think I'm drinking vodka stolio by the
way as a flavored vodka stolios it's
good that's a good flavor I've had that
yeah that's like my next choice if they
don't have that stolio
a good vodka it's not bad what are like
the what are the shitty overrated ones
and what are the good ones uh basically
vodka's vodka so as long as it's uh most
most quality vodkas are like four times
uh filtered so like as long as it's like
filtered three or four four times
usually and if it's not a plastic bottle
you're good to vodka's vodka this was my
grandmother's thing my grandmother
growing up she used to have vodka on the
rocks and a snifter glass and she was
like if you mixed vodka she'd be like
mad at you because she's like you don't
mix if you mix Vodka get the cheapest
that was our whole thing
you should get the cheapest because
you'll still get like that ridiculous
ethanol like off with uh but like dude
don't pay you know 90 for some like
branded vodka or whatever like like Gray
Goose soda's stupid Gray Goose soda is
not necessary at all like Tito's is fine
like Tito's
Tito's great I love Kettle Kettle is
great my favorite vodka though if
anything is only like potato vodka
because it has a different texture has a
different consistency because the
different starches and potatoes so it's
more smoother it's velvety so if you
find like polish vodka of any kind get
that
but as far as like main mainstream like
Belvedere is potato vodka oh all right
classic and then that's a pricing vodka
that's the same price Gray Goose but if
you're gonna have something on the Rocks
be able to use fantastic well me and Jay
got into a big fight at the cellar one
night because he loves vodka and I was
like I bet you can't tell the difference
between like high-end vodka and just
handle plastic bottles he was like I can
definitely tell and we bet a couple
bucks put Two Shots Out blind taste test
he got it wrong every single time every
time he did probably five shots and got
it wrong every time so I was like there
you go what do you say to that he was
like you got me but I'm hammered
but it just goes to show you that that's
all branding all that Chopin all
that crap it's actually pretty good but
but it's hard to find and it's not there
but yeah no vodka like listen vodka's
vodka like you're either taking a shot
of it or mixing it and unless you're
drinking it straight on the Rocks like
you know I've worked at some bars where
like it's like they were really shady
they would swap out oh there you go and
these dudes were paying for it and
they're like yeah this is like the only
thing I drink I'm like yeah yeah well I
mean I always spent every year I've
tried to guess what the drink of the
summer is gonna be yeah like there's
like you know how like remember when
like dude Bros icing Bros
and it became like self-actualized and
they're like yeah we're drinking smart
off ice now and then like there was Rose
and that started as a big joke every
summer drink starts as a joke yep where
guys are like with each other
right and then they like it that's it
100 True remember at the seller ones
years ago you know Liz the manager would
drink apple Spritz every night Michelle
wolf would drink after all Spritz I
remember one night I think you were
doing it Ari shaffir was doing it we all
just ordered like we'll drink after all
Spritz three or four and I'm like these
are delicious right yeah I did
that with trans
oh and then here I am later a year and I
know I'm in an alley but yeah no it's
it's true it starts off as a joke but
you gotta you gotta act tough for ten
minutes and then you you can be I mean I
remember if you are tough they don't
mind I'm moving my yard at the seller
ones tough guy he's you know and he's
he's sipping a uh I think he's sipping a
uh Bailey's Irish cream on the rocks and
I was like ooh tough guy is a joke and
he goes I'll still kick your ass
like I know but I can't make a joke
about it I know right we all know you'll
be right away I'm like you will kick my
ass for the record but it's a funny
thing to see a tough guy drinking yeah
you're drinking milk milk that'll
you up yeah yeah I will say I don't know
if we've ever done a lot have we done a
White Russian episode no I can't believe
that I think we have a very long time
ago I think maybe well that's the
problem
I'm not sure but I always think of that
scene from The Departed uh like when he
orders a cranberry juice
period and then he kicks the out of
him dude perfectly trust me the biggest
people I've ever met drink like
well the toughest black guys in the
world have like a blue lagoon or
whatever there's always some crazy blue
thing there you go wow is it a bloody
mary beautiful yeah these are Micheladas
see these look ready for like Instagram
like I love the look that's really the
key now it's like every bar I see on
like Third Avenue by Bowery and all that
lower area like by Houston it's all
these cute bars with stripes and palm
trees and like pink flare here and there
and it's all Instagram it's all luck
it's like it's like a John Taffer thing
it's like a bar rescue it's like they
saw that and we're like oh we'll just
follow what he says to do I mean my
buddy owns a bar down in it's one of the
bars that I put on my list oh I can't
wait to hear this I want to hear this he
he's big on like you gotta have the
mural to take a picture I don't know if
you gotta have like and we're doing a
version of that like you know you got to
put out the clips you gotta right you
know we go on the road I take pictures
after the show like it's not because I'm
like you know I want to take a billion
pictures and it's a very nice
interaction but at the same time I'm
like yeah they're gonna post it so what
happened at the show who's this guy you
know like there's an element of that
that sure sure you got a brand gotta get
your word out right so they must love
the wall because it's free they build
one wall and then people take photos the
crazy part about these comedy clubs is
like we work at some places that are
like you're like are you guys stupid I
know I I there's some answers yes yeah
there's the comedy club I mean some of
them are great and then some of them
don't last you can't believe I'm like
hey I got 250 women coming for this show
they're all going to want to take
pictures I'm game I'm gonna do it for
free I'm not get you know like let's do
it and then they go oh okay
um I guess you could do it next to the
garbage can uh in the darkness and
you're like can you just like like you
don't see yeah this is free advertising
right I gotta stop playing the trash can
Comedy Club this place sucks yeah that's
right uh yeah I'm just like I can't
believe it and then you see these
pictures and like every person I take a
picture was like ah the lighting sucks
it's like yeah I wouldn't post that
either right you know like we all want
to look skinny and fun I know it's sad
but true all right you wanna you wanna
should we should we cheers these um
let's go oh michelada so what's in that
again it's just a it's like a light
Mexican beer we're using window today uh
some tomato juice worship it's like a
bloody mary but with beer basically the
same thing all right you know salty and
rim on the on the rim I love that Rim
right I love a good room
I like the tahin very nice sometimes I
go no I love a good Ram you do it yeah
you get a little you get a little uh
salted I only do half because some
people like they'll you know it gives
you an option you know you can switch it
up but with tahin it's delicious so that
is refreshing and it's a bloody mary can
be it's almost like like tomato soup
have you ever you know have you ever had
a bloody Bowl uh-oh yeah it's with beef
broth yeah yeah they're very 80s New
York thing like a steakhouse thing
actually first I discovered it at uh JG
melon yeah he's a data girl who lived
around the block from JG melons in the
Upper East Side and that was like The
Hangover spot you get a burger and a
bloody bowl that bar was great too this
was classic gone right it's gone is it I
don't know one in the upper race I don't
know is it still there they that was a
hang
a few months at the end that's what I
call my wife
yeah I lived on 72nd like three months
ago it's a great burger great burger
good vibe good vibe old New York Vibe
right and so I mean it's like you got
the PJ Clarks yeah no that's what I'm
thinking it closed is PJ Clark still
open that's the one I'm 55th and third
well that one I hope so because that
one's been there I mean they do like
episodes of Mad Men there yeah wow and
there's like bartenders that have become
like famous there really yeah well that
guy Doug was a legend he he said
something I remember years ago I
remember I thought it was such a cool
thing because some some woman goes in
there do you have any Red Bull vodka and
he goes we don't serve Red Bull here he
goes you want to get energy have a
coffee
and I was like yeah I love that
energy let's ride in your work you know
like that's like the undone bow tie they
were classy and also I remember you know
I know you know just I would drink Bud
Lights there because they were five
bucks each you know but then you know I
remember I befriended a guy there one
night when I was like a young comic and
he just bought me around after the round
it was one of those nights where like
some dude just got me up I love
that they don't know what that means to
a poor guy when someone's just buying
you free it's like oh my God it's a
heaven I went there my friend's dad used
to take us here when we were really
young and we didn't get id'd I mean we
just walk in and uh we were kids but he
was his dad was he passed away it was so
funny he was like that inappropriate guy
that would take you out yes where uh he
would say like I remember he walked
up to a woman in a bar once when we were
PJ Clarkson he was just like lady what I
wouldn't give to you up the ass and
we were like and we were like what the
and she was like you
and I was like I am so sorry I
you not she kisses me in front of
him to like be like you that's a
gentleman I'm apologizing for you went
home with her come on yeah and then as I
was kissing her he gave me one of these
behind to like
[Music]
in the ass
to the can you set him up I'll
knock him down
he was arrested
party guy right in the back I'm still
friends with his kid I mean his kid
Dennis who's I mean I'm a kid my age but
I mean that was his name was also Dennis
they were Dennis Jr Dennis senior and
they were a hilarious young you
know you better mold he must have been a
ball at a different time too
like yeah very different time the idea
like that you know not not to say like
we want people screaming at people to
no it's not an admirable thing to
say to a woman I think we're all in
agreement pick and basketball like you
got you got the assist he did he got hit
but he got the assist you know it's like
I was watching uh old episodes of Boston
Legal on Hulu Boston Lee it's
solid really James Spader and William
Shatner oh people love that show and
that had a long run let me tell you
something Spader is so good I
thought you were talking about Boston
Public no that southern comedian like he
was like oh
is that who it was he was a southern
community
dude James Spader is so Charming
they say on this show I can't
believe the they get away with it
there's a line where
this is like this on like NBC or fox or
something I would think yeah so it's on
basic Network TV and there's a line
where the judge says the Spader he's
like uh he's like if it stinks I don't
eat it and he goes really I go by the
opposite motto this is a network you're
like oh that was a four right every
episode is him just one of his
co-workers like he's just cool I just
remember that show for its commercials
they like how excited it was yeah like
Spader yeah Shatner like that was like a
big it was like a heavyweight Fighters
Spader's cool on this
show
oh I know she was on it but she's a
hot judge I think or the the head lawyer
but it's crazy the you could get
away with oh yeah just like clearly like
that was a cool back in the day
damn she was a die
she's so hot she there she's
going nuts now when hot women get old
they lose it because they're like wait
what's where is everybody I remember
like tail end of Spin City when she came
on I was like oof she was so hot so hot
that's what got uh Michael J shaking
I was like oh my God look at her uh then
Charlie Sheen took over he was awesome
right yeah he's always fun love
Sheen yeah you ever watch those Two and
a Half Men episodes you ever watched an
episode no I've never watched a full app
it's hard to get through there you go I
get why this is successful yeah for sure
you go this is like junk food candy
you're like I I don't like it's an
everything bagel at two in the morning
with a half a red onion yeah yeah
because I I watched that and I was like
I get it I get it like there's not one
thing like people it made fun of it but
I was like you know Charlie Sheen's just
like doing Charlie Sheen yeah like it's
like it's a great character right it's a
great character and you go I know what
I'm getting yeah no surprise Here
Charlie she's gonna be an ass like be a
this womanizer guy and like the other
guy's Gonna Be A Nerd and the kid's
gonna be you know the the punk nose kid
and then that's it you know and people
work a job all day they come home
they want to watch right you know
they don't want to be like uh dazzled
with like uh you know know intellectual
hey what's your trauma today it's
like how about we just watch Charlie
Sheen I will say though I did try to
watch Big Bang Theory and I'm like I
can't get through 10 minutes it was too
nerdy they had no relatability like the
thing that they were relatable on was
with like a nerd culture that I couldn't
I guess because but I would watch old I
watched like Frasier now and I'm like
this holds up so hard well yeah
Frazier's Frasier is incredible
Frazier won all those Emmys with
Seinfeld was at its peak like Erasure
was winning you know like no tossed
salad and scrambled egg yeah great show
he'd be a fun guest
let's get Kelsey Grammer on there it's a
bag of blows right you might have to get
a mirror on the table
that dude definitely lives
he's from another era of like I didn't
talk about eras like the way he was paid
when you were like the lead of a sitcom
on NBC forget about it like we you know
think of like Jordan in the Bulls
Frasier and a whole industry like yeah
the reason and he was on drugs for the
whole first few seasons he was
completely tired it's crazy that he's
even cooler pulled it off yeah I think
they had like multiple interventions and
I think he even said like later on he's
like John Mahoney who played his dad he
was like that dude is like an actual
father I don't think he had a dad I
think he had a horrible childhood like
really tragic and he was like that guy
was like my actual Dad wow crazy
can I just can't imagine your your
Frasier you know like you're just like
walking around like and everyone just
like lit you like you have to be you're
on drugs and I'm just the boss like
everyone is like also you're so
dignified in the show you're just like
squeaking an alley then you come on like
I'm listening yeah yeah right the the
the dichotomy between who he played and
what he was right or I we what we think
he was yeah High Society so true that
was a great some of those shows still
hold up oh what I mean Niles is great
what are you guys doing to me yeah
I said no shots this was salaky's uh
experiment oh and where is he for this
cues what are you talking
about I can't believe how much branded
stuff you guys have this pack has been
around for five minutes
we might be drunk snifters and glasses
and our own whiskey too the whiskey we
also have Bodega cat whiskey love it
available online this Micheladas is
really good spot really good for
the summer it's awesome I love it you
know what I love it it slows me down
yeah you can't chug this no no we did
the beer I had that beer well that's why
that's why the tequila shots there right
there you go give us some wrecks I want
some more racks
with the the ones and two
got me on to help the listeners out hell
yeah
um
on a great date last night and I think
everyone should do it okay okay drift in
it's on the West Side Highway hmm if you
go oh walk down outdoor so if you want
to impress a woman like I'm saying to
the mail listeners
if you're looking to like have an easy
easy date night yep yep you walk down
Christopher all the way to the water
drifton is on the right if you take a
right after Christopher they also have
Oysters they got food and stuff but I
wouldn't go there for food because
there's if you look at it from
from the Hudson River looking at it yeah
there's a right side on the left side go
to the right side the left side you need
a reservation the right side is just a
bar got it so you go to the right side
you go to the bar they got chairs out
they got you know they got morning bags
cornhole yeah and you can just have an
easy like the the thing you want on a
date is to look like you have a plan oh
dude you must clean up with your plan
you're all playing this is all planned
so you go to this place you go on the
right side even if you went with a
couple of guys there's gonna be women
there it's on the water that's cool and
it's cool and nice and fun and you look
like you know something and it's not
busy no no it's not crazy that's a great
spot if you go on a Tuesday night yeah
they own like all these kind of water
bar they must have a deal with like the
the mayor or some yeah that place
is great too that place on a boat but
you got a grand Bank yeah but that's
like get that's a panty dropper they
have a great place it's a submarine that
goes to the bottom of the Titanic
so this is the side that's reservations
but if you go to the other side there's
not and then I went to Tacoma I gotta
say there's a bunch of locations easy
half a second the guac was on the table
two minutes later yep Margaritas in hand
to Comey what a like a solid date night
spot there's one on Bleaker there's one
in SoHo and now there's one in Brooklyn
right so I I these are just I don't know
what places when you go on a date the
work have you guys ever gone on a date
where you're like Hey we're gonna go to
this place and then they're like we're
full and then you have to Now find yes
the nearest most perfect place and you
just have this woman falling around like
yes did he do anything the pressure's on
right oh I've seen that place I've
walked by there it's on there's a one on
Bleaker literally looks like you're
they've built it to look like you're
outside on a street corner in Mexico
yeah it feels like that
yeah I I think that's a great date spot
okay so and the menus like sushi where
you you tick it off like I'll take a
shrimp taco you know it's not too
complicated
um but I wanted to know I came on here
and you guys gave me a little homework
but I I'm sorry we know you're you're
good for it I well what's your favorite
road bar
like not in New York not in New York I
got some New York ones here for people
that come to New York but what is your
favorite
we are all people comics on the road
yeah we all have a drink yeah what is
your go-to road bar like is there a city
bar combo that sticks with you
yeah you know what I love I love what's
it called it's in Chicago it's like a I
got a couple Chicago it's the Capone
spot and they it's in the movie Thief
with James Khan okay which is a
great movie by the way yeah I just
watched it recently oh yeah the Green
Mill I love it I've done a show there me
too great that's a really cool it's like
a Capone bar and another great Chicago
one is Shaw's it's like a seafood
restaurant but it's one of those like
old school Green Mill the show there is
great right yeah it's like a daytime
paper machete yes I've done the show
it's got that wrap around bar and
everyone there is like cool and smart
and like ready like to hear yes some
material there it is it's a beautiful
Broadway Bar so that's that's a good one
I'm trying to think of other ones I mean
here's my Chicago la I love muso and
franks I love old-timey bars I had an
old school one but in the 80s I went to
a different era what do you got Frolic
room
[Music]
just a fun drink is gonna happen there
it's got the the stars on the sidewalk
yeah yeah yeah yeah I actually have been
yeah I think I had a killer her this is
great Chicago I had lone wolf in the
West Loop let's pull it up pull it up on
an elephant West Loop I mean these
places better give me a favor what's
good about this I know right
in area Town West Loop is our West
Village oh yeah great area a little bit
of Upper Crust area you can go to a lot
of different parts I love the look of it
this place is open later than most okay
I think it's a 3 A.M bar big Square bar
easy to get into there's sometimes a
line but again like I want Vibe and you
know if you want people hanging out I
want people you know so this is a great
like I could be there late I love a bar
that gives a because you feel it
right when you walk in you're like are
these people planned all of this they
know what they're doing here totally
it's right near the soil house in
Chicago which I I mean like good so uh
so like there's like it's just a good
area Asha Falls across the street grape
grape Burger great burger oh yeah are
you a Soho House guy I am okay we went
Jared took me there once oh really we
went we went there I think I think it
was on Christmas Day we did go on
Christmas Jared came over to watch Hoops
I had a couple friends that we watched
hoops and then we ordered Chinese food
everyone took two dumps and sampled my
fresh new bidet not too much Chinese
food and alcohol we were just concerned
the day it's a great bidet but uh I'd
recommend that the day yeah but day it
was great tonight we went to Seoul house
that was pretty that was pretty Swanky
that was pretty cool it's great there's
a good scene there that you know that's
a fun just be able to like sauce is good
it's a base great we have somewhere to
go totally right and it's also anywhere
you go the one in Nashville that might
be my favorite hotel to stay at on the
road really period and you could stay
there without being a member what so
they have a pool bar area and also it's
not on look at that that so beautiful
love here's the thing about Nashville
is you don't want to be on Broadway you
don't want to be here no chicks
on the pedal bike you don't want any of
that so the whole city runs electricity
it's just biking on those damn drunk
chicks just powering the whole thing
this is a great bar area but then
there's bars near that that area of
Nashville where the sohos is if I don't
know what that area is called if you can
look it up
um tons of great bars on that street
that's all adjacent to
all that kind of like what's going on
there yeah and I walked around there
with Theo once it was like I was with
Elvis oh it was insane yeah yeah that
they went nuts also favorite bar
Nashville Red Door Tavern pull it up
that door I'm I'm like this is plug City
big I know but I want you to go to these
places I think you guys would like them
I love them Lucy and I we go and smoke
cigs at Red Door I don't even smoke
cigarettes
look at the picnic tables outside that's
not the one there's another red door not
Red Door Tavern Red Door Saloon there we
go Nashville I love a saloon yeah yeah
yeah Nashville
it's just a great indoor outdoor this
bar right now is fist pumping yeah right
no I but I Love This Bar like give us
you got to give us a good Boston one too
you got Boston time the Boston one oh
there's only one there's I I forgot to
write but I can't believe that's the one
on my list from Boston Red Door okay Red
Door Saloon great spot makes you want to
smoke a cigarette outside man even if
you don't smoke cigs there's always a
hang lots of musicians it looks kind of
grimy in a good way grimy in a good way
is all is kind of the theme of my list
right now
Frolic room is in the same vein as this
yeah best bartenders I've ever seen at
The Red Door Saloon in Nashville wow
there's honestly They are packed what's
the criteria for best bartenders quick
look in the eye ready for an order if
you stammer a little bit they'll give
you an extra second like I I think they
like these guys appreciate
you know like a little bit of like
energy when you come in yeah yeah right
okay yeah you're like a Zagat I dude I
think about this a lot like and I hate
bad recommendations okay when someone
comes to me with a recommendation that's
born about them than it is about you I
think it's the most selfish thing in the
world I agree I went to I was in where
did I go I was in Houston and someone
told me they're like go to bar taco I
was like that's a chain
do you know me at all like I hated the
person you're gonna shake shack yeah
ever heard of it the great burger yeah
Whataburger yeah okay so yeah what do we
got in what's Boston The Departed bar is
that the one well the one I would say
yeah I I think the new so there's two
places I would give one is owned by the
Garrett that has bars here in New York
and it's borachata it's a it's like a
speakeasy behind a taco place
hmm I would look I I don't have the name
Boston Boston
Speakeasy Garrett group look up that
because it's I don't like the Garrett
group's bars here are they the ones who
do off the wagon no no those are my
that's my buddy those are great those
are great if you go to the green not the
Green Mill the mill the hill they have
there it is hair of the dog hair the dog
off the wagon Down the Hatch that's all
there that's it yeah this is called
what's it called porchito
that's it great bar okay that's new I
went there last time I was in Boston but
the seaport I love Boston dude I
love Boston I grew up in Needham which
is outside of Boston I think I'm gonna
take my next special at the Wilbur The
Wilbur I think is the best theater
magical yeah because it's most right
it's the most clubish um but this part I
mean look at that bar I mean you grew up
in in this grew up in Needham so like
growing up like I you know I never went
I didn't have a Boston adulthood I've
always been in New York but I would say
the whole Seaport District didn't really
exist when I grew up there now it's been
all built up there's a bar that was the
first bar open in the seaport Lucky
Lounge Lucky Lounge is a fun time and it
reminds me of a picture of Lucky lounger
I love going to Lucky Lounge open late
fun crew they used to do bands they
don't anymore because I think the
neighbors complain but like look at this
place this is kind of in the vein oh
right up my anal right look at this I
just got laid off I want to Tie
One On right yeah and I want to do it in
good company we almost got it my buddy
and I my buddy almost got in a fight
last time I was there he like some guy
had a it was like an older guy because
here's what I love about a bar and the
bars I like hanging out with are when
you can't figure out who goes like a mix
crowd it's just drinkers right you know
like I like when it's just people who
are like we're having a night let's just
drink and you can and there's no like
white you know like you know you you go
to a party like oh it's all white women
no no this is everything you don't know
it could be a bachelorette party it
could also be like a bunch of dudes that
are out for the night it could be all
Races religions backgrounds socio I love
the color too it's like a cassavettes
film or some dude the right side is
like this booze and stuff and then the
left side is like more bar room yeah wow
I just love it there I'm a huge fan
lucky but we like we were we were there
my buddy and I my buddy's like hammered
and he looks at this guy and he had the
creases in his shirt still like it
looked like he just unfolded it from the
store and my buddy looked at him he's
like what's with the creases and the
guy's like you want to fight about it
like right away that's Boston for you
right he went straight Boston immediate
immediately okay so that's my Boston
wreck that's a good one Atlanta oh hit
me with Atlanta my favorite one of my
favorite bars in the world are you gonna
say Claremont Lounge I I like the clown
I mean you can't a lot of nights there I
mean I like that we're all just seasoned
Road dogs and we know every yeah
I mean you just go straight there after
a gig well I went there it's a
woman-owned uh
strip club yeah and we I went with
Michelle oh so Michelle and I sit down
and the woman whose daughter like runs
it was like oh my God Michelle like was
so pumped saw Michelle and we're in a
strip club amazing she gives us a book
about the place she tells us the whole
history women own they all have health
insurance you know you start to feel
good about going to a strip club so the
best bar in the world Johnny's Hideaway
in Atlanta oh
look at that it it is too full and they
don't let you dance on the dance they
have a dance floor that they kick you
off of if you bring the glass on the
dance floor right right they have like a
no glass and they get they serve you in
crystal glasses yeah it's so cool it's a
fun cool bar and again 20 bucks at the
door there's always a line you got to
give 20 bucks to the bouncer yep it'll
get you ahead of the line you feel like
you're in Key West when you go in there
you leave yeah he was in the 70s or
something I will be going there it's a
hot spot it's dark it's hot that was on
my list for specials too I just like
Atlanta I love Atlanta hotlanta Love
Atlanta I I mean what's not to like
about Atlanta yeah like that's like kind
of like I go there every time I'm like I
think this is the future like if like it
feels like black gay what a lot of gay
black people well I'm saying like it has
everything like it doesn't feel like you
know again to like going to a bar
especially Johnny Johnny the highway and
you go I can't believe every type is
here yes it is a lot of Hotmail so
that's not yeah that's the prevalent I
love as a perk
um Clint Eastwood yeah
okay so on Johnny's Hideaway
the bar that reminds me most of Johnny's
Hideaway on the road is in Dallas Inwood
Tavern
okay I don't know because I'm always out
in Addison doing that so I drive down
okay so after this is Inwood Tavern I
mean does that not look like it looks
like a tattoo spot a little bit you're
right
whoa I've been here you've been here
with the guy who worked for the Dallas
Mavs once yeah we had a fun night great
bar okay then he took me out later
tonight we went to inbred Tavern not
nearly as good but uh no it was a great
bar Chicago I had Lone Wolf and then Old
Town Ale House you've definitely Old
Town ale house
that was in a movie too that was where
Ebert used to drink yes Bourdain did an
episode there and that was around the
block
yes right it's right near zany so I've
had some and of course the owner uh does
nude uh paintings of everybody yes
that's right he's got some great
trumpets
two Zanies waitresses both plus size in
that bar and uh they were huge
years and years ago cheap too it's for
that area oh yeah okay now and the
tamale guy comes in
it's a great bar it's just like and you
do feel the most in Chicago yes you know
like it feels like everyone says the
Bears there right that's the owner we
need a good we need a good SF oh I got
one
I got one next to my list all right
Buddha Bar Buddha I think pull it up
something better than drinking in
Chinatown in San Francisco I I
completely agree it is the best drinking
area most underrated drinking area there
are all these little tiny bars so like
Buddha Bar is like the bar might be 10
feet wait a minute is this on the pier
no okay okay I mean look at this bar wow
I love it I love it San Francisco
Chinatown Chinatown baby you ever go to
yank sing in in SF is that a dim sum dim
sum yes I think I have did my boy Adam
Swig take you there well Swig that guy's
the best he's the best that guy
I hooked Jared up with my buddy Swig
who's like the mayor of SF oh
really nothing makes me feel more like
like a comedian than when another
comedian is like here's my guy there
yeah yeah you know like and he's got
this guy take care of him take care of
him and he's this Jewish guy who puts on
these Jewish things but he's like cool
Jew you know like it's like DJ
Juiceman more uh you know you're right
listen more uh modest Yahoo
one of my favorites also Vesuvius is
across um oh yes do you know that place
I've been there yeah that's a sexy spot
Vesuvius going upstairs and having a
martini there that's a great time
that's across from um cops right right
there's a spot on the pier Matt if you
can find it but look at look how sexy
that is I know that city is in shambles
right now but I love it I don't
think it's in shambles I think the media
portrays it in Shameless I think you're
right it might be I think like yeah
you're not gonna go to the tenderloin to
drink like no but like the marina is
awesome I mean that's like West Village
for here like I love it again it's a
high-end area but it's great and that
Old Trolley goes by the architecture
beautiful it's it's like one of the most
European feeling in American cities Nola
has that feel yeah I love San Francisco
in a way that I like can't explain like
it feels like it's like yes if the food
there you ever go to the sandwich place
the Italian sandwich place I go every
time I'm there I go to this I'm a
seafood there I'm a sodomori guy
what's that what's the uh Swan oyster
Depot yes I think Bourdain went there
have you ever been there
look up American Joe's San Francisco
um that is one of the best bars
in the country Original Joe's that's
what it's called
um how about San Diego do we have
anything I have a San Diego spot you're
a tank I don't know San Diego
that well so I just did San Diego I've
been doing the store in La Jolla which I
like that town is just like uh yeah
that's a kill box uh no it is that's a
great room murder there
um okay Molinari Delicatessen to finish
out San Francisco that is the best
Italian sandwich I have ever had in my
entire life they sent me a bunch of
because I talked about it once I mean
look at that oh my God look at right up
my alley Molinari I sit outside in one
of those chairs there's like four chairs
I get the sandwich inside it is well I
mean look at that come on baby that
should be in between two legs that is
beautiful I want to put my dick in there
holy
a good Italian sandwich why are you
hosting a food bar shoes
really this you really should this
should be a part of Jared's luxury
lounge and it should be uh you should be
doing like food on a YouTube channel I
review I I could really review a place
like I because I I just hate bad
recommendations like in a way that like
really makes me annoyed like that's
that's the first episode that you would
say bad recommendations yeah this
is how you give a good wreck and you
well because when I was doing all the
board Lord stuff I was yelling at the
charcuterie boards and like I was doing
them because they were getting attention
people were like him and they were funny
so I'm looking at these charcuteries and
the main the main premise of board Lord
was you get to a party and if they're
thinking of themselves in their
Instagram picture more than they're
thinking of your stomach they're a piece
of I love it you know what I mean
and I think a lot of times
recommendations go that way they're like
oh I want to look like the person who
sent you to this place but it's like do
you even think like I got I'm going to
Raleigh soon I like Raleigh it's a good
rally good food great are you going this
month yeah I think they're doing the uh
I could be wrong but don't they do that
big Festival the the carnival I forgot
what it's called it's in Raleigh uh
you know what they do like the uh
look up big Festival it's like a it's
like games and turkey legs and
oh okay I love that what's it
called whether you're trying to get off
the sauce or you're trying to stop
spending all the money in your
retirement fund quitting can sometimes
be tough if you're looking to quit that
nasty hand-to-mouth habit you're not
alone fume can help it's a cool
Innovative device that takes the bad out
of bad habit few more places Electronics
vapor and harmful chemicals with all
natural flavored air this is uh you know
this is you want to get off this stuff
use it if your fidgety fume has movable
parts and magnets to keep your hands
occupied and with an incredible airflow
and awesome flavors to choose from you
can totally customize your experience
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over a hundred thousand customers
and thousands of success stories and
there's no reason that can't be you join
fume in accelerating Humanity's backup
from destructive Habits by picking the
journey pack today head to trifum.com
and use code drunk to save 10 off when
you get the journey pack today that's
try
fum.com and use code drunk to save an
additional 10 off your order today
fume.com code drunk bring your grooming
routine
manscapes brand new handyman electric
face shaver makes looking great super
quick and convenient whether you're just
trying to shape up your beard or want to
chop everything off and start over with
a with its hybrid long hair leveler and
foil shaver blades the handyman has got
you covered folks oh yeah
oh the compact design makes it amazing
for travel and with 60 Minutes of run
time and a five minute Quick Charge
option you won't be out of battery
anytime soon you got that right I keep
mine in my suitcase I use it on the road
it's the best thing for you you gotta
have it I love it it's got a light on it
it gets all those nooks and crannies
without nicking you no Nicks
just like the basketball team are they
in the playoffs no Knicks I'm drunk uh
if you're trying to seriously change up
your look
add the beard hedger to Your Arsenal too
it's built to cut through even the
thickest facial hair with a single
stroke saving you tons of time so get 20
off and free shipping with the code
drunk at
manscape.com damn that's a steal folks
whoo baby that's a Dior and K at
manscape.com 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com use promo code drunk hit
the refresh button with manscape and
clean up your genitals folks thank you
back to the show not Renaissance
barbecue no Raleigh's a great City
Suburban combo it's under the radar too
under the radar great City people are
moving there like crazy
um but I'm getting recommendations right
now and it's like
like choose a path for me like have some
confidence like yes if I could remember
the name of this I'd wreck the out
send it to me I I mean it gets me kind
of annoyed because I'm like this person
sent me recommendations for Raleigh and
it's like the the message went three
Scrolls and I'm like you get one night
we have one weekend no dinners we can
only go at like five at the latest yeah
you know we're in a weird position give
me some bars here and we can only eat at
five and drink at midnight right so our
recommendations like are you thinking of
me if you're like go to this Italian
spot like I'm not gonna go to that I
went to a cool spot right and then the
spot right next to the good nights Club
where it used to be I think it's a new
location oh the Food Spot with the with
the uh mechanical bull oh I don't know
that place uh it was an outdoor like
bearish spot yeah that I know that I'm
thinking of but yeah I just like Raleigh
I mean great to underrated like uh not
pretentious Town they're just fun
wholesome salt of the earth people I
agree with that okay okay so are we
gonna do New York or whatever we'll go
to New York last okay we're gonna
discuss our favorites
um San Diego tavoli bar that's like an
old place that's like
I like gold but there was another bar I
couldn't think of the name it might be
tavoli I'm pretty positive this is a
tavoli here it's a deli
this is more Sports bar-ish San Diego
that looks like something
also what's the area of San Diego that's
like above it a little bit there's a gas
light which is like their downtowny I
wasn't a fan of Gaslight there's another
area that's like more towards the beach
Pacific Beach look up Pacific Beach bars
because I think that's where I'm pb pb
so the kids call it
okay yeah we got anything here
oh I've gone out here yeah it's a great
place to go out great spot it's a rowdy
rowdy area it's it's kind of the fratty
area sure like there's some really good
fun bars there yeah I got can I give a
weird random recipe
Atlantic City if you're ever there
Tony's Baltimore Grill
let's pull it up well this guy's got a
lot to pull up here he's Tony Baloney
some tabs what the did he just
write in there he had one michelada
you got nothing on Nola huh because I'll
do Nola if you if you're not uh no I
don't have a nice boy you get
like a rum and coke for six bucks in a
pint glass that's great yeah oh I've
been there
I mean that's that meatball sub looks
amazing that's heavy stuff so with New
Orleans I always get sent to like places
that people know already like what's the
Wine Place that's the best wine bar in
the country oh there's bacchanal that's
what everyone says and then you kind of
feel like hack yeah
like Magazine Street right that's got
some cool magazine is great like
Frenchman's a hot spot but uh like
there's a uh Miss maze on Napoleon yeah
I've been there it's killer no drink is
more than two dollars that's like their
thing and you talk about a mixed crowd
you get the old guy who just lost his
job you got the divorcee you got the
weird like loud black chicks you got the
gutter punks it's everything I love that
Liz sent me to a place in New Orleans
where it was a laundromat or something
do you know what I'm talking about
there's a couple of those yeah just like
they have the off the wagon whatever
there's a few there's a guy there who
owns like five bars Igor's Buddha belly
uh
uh blanking uh uh Checkpoint Charlie and
then Sean Patton sent me to a place with
the uh the Irish coffee Frozen Irish
coffees froze oh bali's Molly's on the
market that place was great that's a
great spot I enjoyed that
um and then I went to the the bar that
rotates was kind of cool oh the Carousel
Bar yeah it was cool
yes whoever's in town that week goes
there if you want like a good cocktail
but still have like a a Divi Vibe
bartonique okay in New Orleans yes in
New Orleans okay incredible
it's
t-o-n-i-q so okay I don't know can I get
a gin and toniq
tonic no it's not it's not but it's a
key I know I know the point when we say
tonic is it is that how you said it yeah
I've been there I've been there twice
I get it yeah it's so good because the
bathrooms are great but it's still like
a divey atmosphere right it's kind of
Rowdy a little bit but you get offense
fantastic like actually nice cocktails
yeah are we doing anything like are we
doing any like Florida or Midwest type
stuff
I got a place in Delray only because my
parents live down there oh okay there's
a great bar on the beach called the Sand
Bar because Tampa's got some spots too
Tampa has spots Tampa's great well
Tampa's I'm gonna be there in December
and I just did it I'm like I
love Tampa's young too yeah it just
feels like I feel too old to even be in
the pound there like it's like really
young uh The Sandbar in Delray if you
want like this yeah yeah holy are
you you're showing all these pictures in
the episode right this is awesome right
right across from the beach it's a party
like people are there to party they're
not there to like this is a off the
beach bar you don't want the on the
beach bar because people are there to
like be at the beach this is like the
kids are away right we're gonna go to
this bar and really do it up and this is
like my family we go across the street
at the beach and I just like we we my
brother and I every woman in this
pictures are as hot as well they
know what they're doing I mean Delray to
me as far as recommendations are
concerned I would put on my like someone
was like where should I do a weekend
with my boyfriend I was like go to
Delray I don't even know Delray what is
Delray Delray is so there's like Boca is
like a little bit Inland and then Del
Rey is like on the beach so if you went
to If you flew into West Palm half hour
south of West Palm okay and also half
hour north of Fort Lauderdale so Miami's
Miami like we've all been to Miami I get
what I'm getting there it's Miami Beach
it's great it's fun it's International
fine Fort Lauderdale is kind of
considered like the cheaper version of
Miami you're gonna get a little bit more
Floridian you're a little more Taurus
much better comedy crowds in Miami in
Fort Lauderdale Miami no Fort Lauderdale
and Fort Lauderdale I think the crowds
are way better I think it's more I think
Miami's more of a transplant City they
don't give a right you know Fort
Lauderdale is going to be like I've
lived grown up around Fort Lauderdale
yes Del Rey is
you're going to get As Nice a hotel
you're going to be able to like go to
bars and go to eat you're not gonna be
at a nightclub but like I think that's a
weekend if I was to send someone like go
do a weekend yeah you're gonna get the
beach great I love it I can't believe
I'm coming with my weekend
recommendations
I think helpful to us things can be
helpful to everybody well I think if
people are like if you're beautiful if
I'm seven months in with my girlfriend
and we're like What do we do in October
there's the first trip Delray
with Florida I know everybody shits on
Florida but it is a magical place my
parents live in Boca it's a mixed bag
it's like like any state there's great
parts of Florida absolutely I think it's
I'm actually guess what I'm going back
oh breaking news
man oh man I got a bar for you we're
doing a revenge video
I'm doing I'm going back we're doing a
small theater in Naples and I I just
you're gonna be at a theater though it's
gonna be great not in Naples bro it's
still going to be a blood no you hate it
it's good they're gonna come ready to
get trashed right they want to be made
fun you're gonna you're gonna bring like
20 Naples minutes like they're gonna
like want that oh it should be a
bloodbath go to Blue Martini there you
go good so Blue Martini in Naples is
like a whole it's I don't think it's
good it's hilarious it's all men in
their 60s you've been there I like that
it's men in their 60s with like The
Paisley shirt with the collar and the
cuffs and they are just it's like it's
like you landed in 1995. they're all
hitting on women
after it there's no phones out like
there's a DJ it is it is the the the
Pinnacle of old dude hitting on young
women oh I love it look at this I mean
look at that that's it yeah oh this is
great
Blue Martini is a chain but it's like it
I've used it as a punch line many times
like on like Instagram stories or
something like what I'm making fun of
the bachelor I get more messages from
people being like dude you've never been
more right about it like that's Blue
Martini I don't know I had a bad night
at a pulse
okay last one
um well I gotta give a shout out to my
buddy in Charleston Charleston is one of
the better drinking eating towns in the
country Charleston's bananas there's
nothing I was I was there on a Monday
this year we did great well we it was
part of a long run coming back yeah so
it was a great great night but it was a
Monday I always say it's New Orleans
with manners I couldn't agree more that
that my buddy's got a bar called Uptown
social he's like they they're killing it
like they're absolutely they've opened
up two more bars since wow laptown
social has this rooftop that like if you
want to like have fun yeah you go look
at this rooftop oh yeah I mean come on
now we're done beautiful and then there
it is wow
holy moly but it's a little young it's a
little young but you're gonna have a
great time like it's as far as base
place to party yeah and he's got another
place called Beau day got another place
called share house so but like all his
bars same as the hair of the dog off the
wagon in New York same bar group got it
oh okay they know what they're doing
they know what they're doing
um and then Leon's the fried chicken
place is like one of the best places in
the world really well what's the deal
with troll I can't tell if there's 12
people who live there or 500 000. I
can't get a read on how many people live
there because it's kind of got a small
town Vibe but then it's always like on
these food shows when my buddy moved
down there I was like I I was like
there's no doubt he's gonna be the mayor
there no I was like I was like this this
fast talking New Yorker yeah coming down
there and and he's like killing it and
I'm ha I'm so happy for him but he's
like building a house all this like
growing Town new airport oh that's a big
deal that's how you know it's coming
great City
we did a pickup game there on Monday
these wouldn't miss a shot
really it's one of the things we're like
these were like all white dudes who were
pulling up from 40. like they're Damian
Lillard there's one guy I'm playing with
we chat for a while he's like oh I know
your comedy we talked a little bit and
he was like uh forgot who the his
last name was but he told me who his
uncle was uh that name sounds familiar
two-time All-Star in the NBA white guy
with a mustache played for Milwaukee I
don't remember his name but he was cool
as and they were all like nice
dudes Charleston's a great great City I
I love it I love your comedy now I'm
gonna beat your ass yeah I love your
comedy you know he was on my team I was
letting them down okay I was costing
them there you go
and there's another Bourdain spot but
I've been Native New Yorker so I I went
to this place before I knew Bourdain
liked it Corner Bistro is a classic it's
great it's great and I actually have a
great story going there recently that's
in the college yeah yeah great I was
there a couple months ago girl text me
that I met on like a dating a few months
ago she was like work I never met her
she's like Corner Bistro now and they I
got there they're outside drinking out
hammered like having a time and then
they just kept bringing over shots and
we're just like chilling in the street
Sunday it's a great spot it's chill it's
cash only which is kind of funny but I
remember I was there like a year ago I'm
chill at the bar and the guy we chat for
a while bartender's a cool guy and he's
like what do you do and I finally like I
don't like saying comic but I feel like
I'm a comic who's like oh man we had a
real we had a real famous comic do a
show here one uh one night and I was
like oh yeah here he goes this guy Mark
Norman
[Applause]
yeah oh really about
yeah and uh but yeah I mean great spot
uh Burger's great the fries are great
yeah killer good good bar and beautiful
like the five block radius of that area
is so pretty of the Village God I mean
I'm gonna give a bar out that's right
around the corner hit me baby wxou oh
I've been there with you I love the rain
the classic it's amazing together well
breed and I have been there together and
my one of my favorite Parts is who
recognizes him versus who recognizes me
some hot girls like are you Jared freed
some dude with one eyebrows like I know
you
what are you gonna do that is a perfect
hole in the wall I hope it never goes
away because the neighborhood used to be
full of these and they're all
dissipating but also cash only by the
cash on yeah is there a link between
cool ass bar I guess they can get away
with it well especially in New York
because it means people will get the
out of there like right you
know and also we walk in from the cellar
we're we're Kings right cash heavy yes
you know I love it I walk in there you
know what's good about this place I live
I used to live right by here and during
the winter I'd walk by and after enough
people come in and out the windows are
fogged yes because it's just hot sexy
drinking in there right and you know
it's cold outside it's a great Vibe it's
a great Vibe and every bar that we've
talked about the one thing that comes
that that red Hue yes
yeah it's a great winter Spot Great
summer I mean summer Bob Seger plays
hourly
that's one of the best songs to hear in
a bar let's talk about some I mean any
Seeger song but like holy like 3
A.M when I hear Night Moves I'm like I
made the right decisions yes I'm so
happy I'm here oh yeah well we're
throwing up I don't even know the name
of this bar but we're in the area
it's called bar and it's on Greenwich
Ave by the way Fiddlesticks isn't bad
pretty good the Frat guys make it over
no Fiddlesticks made a comeback during
the pandemic okay that part is going to
back now that's it big it's creaky it's
like an old ship hold on pull this up
it's just called bar it's on Greenwich
Ave and I think it's called John's bar
or John's maybe try Johns it's a hole in
the wall you can there it is that blue
that blue sign see it says bar that's it
it's about the size of a subway car it's
been there since the who knows when the
30s it's cheap it's dirty and it's
killer I love this area so much great
spot great that that I gotta go there oh
man I don't know it's also cash only
also if we're talking old New York you
can't leave out mix or lace
out of respect you gotta give them a
week ago just I had like an hour to kill
I just popped in there I got this the
potato leek soup
school when was the last time you guys
went to Rudy's where's Rudy that's in
Times Square 44th and 9th yeah it's like
a little Time Square yeah three hot dogs
free hot dogs I drank there with you a
few times yeah oh I've been there with
Che I think yeah he's delivering around
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's a hobby there was always some
shady going down but Rudy's part of
the fact that Rudy's was so clutch is
for a hot dog well not only that but it
was in that area it was hard to find a
place that wasn't a and a
rip-off right right and Rudy's was a
but it wasn't a rip-off no
cheap cheap drinks okay duct tape on the
duct tape on the uh see you know it's
another great New York Bar that I used
to we used to go there in high school
but they changed location the subway in
have you ever been there oh I know the
subway in Old School look at that
yeah oh I know I've seen that
sign
and where was that well it was on 59th
and Lex but they moved over to like York
or something always by dangerfields yeah
yes I know yeah old school oh man I
remember the bartender there uh they
would he was like a character he
when we were kids he grabbed one
of my friends and just stuck his tongue
down his throat oh my God and we were
like oh my God we were drunk we just did
we didn't realize till the next day I'm
like did he just force himself why does
Sam hang out with the most horrific
people
I got a few more you ready I'd like an
abusive bartender who does something
horrible and then he's like shots
Heart of Gold
Spring Lounge oh I love the spring
that's another classic oh my God the
shark on the outside spring lounges
John Mayer hangs out there ah it's tiny
in there too tiny gets a little foggy
this bar not cheap there's the shark
yeah there's the shark great back area
to set yeah I've made out with a lot of
dudes I mean uh yeah a lot of tough fun
times in there down the street mother's
ruin great Mother's food
cocktails good cocktails great food and
good lady lady place the ladies love
Mothers ladies love mother's room it is
a great spot similar area you know it's
kind of a fun West Village spot is a
kettle of fish ever go there I love
all right that's a great bar let's talk
about a dive again those are going away
that's a great phone call your friend
dude meet me at fudge packers are you
sure just it's a cool bar dude just
come say Fuddruckers no no very
different but this place is cash only as
well ATM in there though yeah yeah
and then the Spaniard we went we've got
many times we've got many times I have
to give them a shout out it's only good
on like Sundays Mondays Tuesday it's
weekends it sucks weekends you can't you
don't want to go too busy
um you want to like stay away from it
weekdays there's always going to be
singles I call it the 27 year old
Embassy no because it's all 27 year olds
just all single 27 year olds hanging out
um and it's just a good
place a good area you can go from place
and go places that area needed that bar
it was kind of annoy uh not an oasis a
drought a desert for a while and then
that place open and it changed
everything it's true
there's also a bar down the street
that's a good real real dive uh
it's got the horse on Barrow Street Ale
House oh yeah yeah right down the street
and I've only gone there when I couldn't
get into exactly they're keeping it open
it's kind of like Greenwich comedy club
and a seller but yeah that's just a
great if you really want to get trashed
and eat a quesadilla at 4am and get
trashed quickly they have the the the
touch screens on the waitresses right so
you they'll come up
yeah throw a drink
okay whatever that might be the moment
where I'm an alcoholic where I'm like
yeah they'll get you the drink quicker
what about Bank Street Bar A Bank Street
uh well it's Broom Street Broom Street
Bar
that's a good one right out right
outside of Soho right getting into
Tribeca Broom Street Bar there it is
that's a classroom
used to pick up chicks there that's a
great bar and down the street there's a
bar that got like re-popular uh finales
Yeah it's gotten very Soho that's cool
it's gotten like Celebi a little Celebi
a little like it's gotten very
influencery it's is that what it's
called finale
yeah so what the are we doing right
now we're talking we're on a podcast
talking about our favorite bars but
we're drinking these people want photos
there it is yeah yeah no that's a great
spot it's a great spot that's gotten
tick-tocky yeah I would say that's the
crowd get out of there I was trying to
get hammered and forget about everything
it's another old bar it's further
downtown I'm like kind of like Hudson
oh one of the oldest bugs look up oldest
bars in New York because it's one of
them I know where you're talking about
ear bar that's it come on
it's it's slanted it's so old it's like
crooked because of the it's by the water
there it is the bee up now it's
called ear bar
it's a White Horse Tavern wow we went
there we went there recently they're too
busy yeah but I did sit down there good
burger though good burger good food good
fries crinkle cut that place in the
pandemic was like the hot spot a well
done crinkle cut oh my God put it let's
rank fries though we're rank fries
I go curly well they never lose Curly's
good
Curly's tough to me if they're all well
done curly steak I like I'm a mistake
over curly I like a shoestring I mean I
hate to blow up another if we're talking
about grape fries and a great bar
Minetta dude oh man that is
great I had an issue there the other
night really I had an issue what
happened no they I went to the bar I got
the fries and I go I want them hot I
want them well done I'm not eating fries
that aren't hot and well done they bring
it out they were like stale oh and I go
I don't want to be this guy
but these are just not right and I go
touch them you know put your hand on
them like I need you to know that I'm
not sitting here complaining yeah they
go no this is horrific they bring them
back
second round of fries just as cold as
the first what is going on I don't know
maybe they're losing it oh yeah yeah I
love them and I uh again I um this is me
not trying to cancel them this is me
asking them to improve and okay yeah
where's the point
the path to Redemption guys I was like
why can't they do it with me
I love that place but yeah that's
disappointing I mean look every once in
a while I love Joe's Pizza you go there
late nights sometimes you get in and off
night yeah
let me give an updated uh a new place
that used to be an old place that just
reopened and not just my ladies Milady
miladys was a bar that like I think the
pandemic closed they redid it it's
beautiful so that's what it used to look
like it's Soho oh okay looks fancy it is
it's got a fancy look I mean look at
that it looks cool I think great date
spot Jocelyn Chia is not allowed oh
that's Malaysia sorry okay I had to set
that one up but yeah all right I don't
know my ladies all right I'm into it
mmm all right okay wait hold on I had
one I had one I lost it Cherry Tavern
you want to get crazy Cherry Tower this
is Avenue B and Sixth Street I
think there it is that's where you're
really going to kill yourself wow dude
it's rough
you know it's a cool one in the village
you ever go to Doc holidays oh a great
bar
I got some tahin in the back of my house
now we're going now we're going East
Village doc holidays is great great bar
great bar you want to see the like the
most like up bar is like craft
work have you ever been there I've never
heard of it it's the last time I went
there the bartender was it's all like
it's a punk like tagged up like East
Village
near Thompson's Park last time I went
there the bartender was I was in the
middle of day but the bartender is
sleeping with his like legs kicked up
and there's a bucket of bars oh no no
there's a bucket of beers on the bar and
it just says honor systems get out of
town that's not gonna work
my 14th beer I'm an honorable man
[Laughter]
Horseshoe Bar
wait a minute on Avenue B seventh and B
we called it Horseshoe Bar because it
was a horseshoe shaped bar yeah seventh
and B I think that's what it's oh seven
b is it called it's called that's a
great it's a great bar a lot of
movies where's turkey's Nest that's on
Bedford in Williamsburg oh I wouldn't
know that it's a cool but it's a
cool spot on the island I don't know he
doesn't leave the island my favorite
beer bars in New York is drop-off
service oh that's a good spot fans
[Music]
talk about the windows fogging yeah I
can't believe we haven't brought up this
one it's a sleeper it's the East Village
I know it blue and gold oh that is a
great get a glass of Shivers for five
bucks that's a good like good ass shots
I got the Shivers when I was in there
that's a great bar yeah I hooked up with
a girl in there she walked up to me and
I her oh really great night Judy
Gold look her up
hold on what's the place with
Eric I well I closed down ah the the
Saint Mark's uh something holiday
cocktails
another classic
cheap drinks Mark and I had some
bombs in that room oh yeah oh my God
Eric I God bless him this guy would run
seven shows a week not one of them was
good but Mark and I would do all of them
everyone dude one run one good show
instead of seven where there's four
people each show yeah let's concentrate
on one thing we were just bomb every
time but I remember like man that one
metal I mean you know you're when
you see that metal it was rough but it
was a great little bar great bar damn is
this entertaining to anyone outside
right I'm wondering I if I up
your podcast
I want someone to I want someone to do
the we might be drunk bartor but they go
to all these places we'll get a bus
this would be great we all go and we
might die but yeah that would be cool
well we won't be riding we won't be
driving the bus we'll just be riding it
but yeah all right might be funnier if
we drive but yeah
wow it's for a podcast yeah 40 tickets
sold 14 people dead
I do know
I thought that closed no I don't think
so the other room I know where you're
talking about a little smelly yeah
Tortilla Flats closed but that's a great
makeout bar the other room is a great
place for like a date and it's hidden I
love when a bar is hidden in a
neighborhood like just tucked away what
the hell is this round beard you what
are we doing uh an hour's going straight
kind of like Margarita
Margarita it's a margarita that's really
expensive uh no just made with Grand
Marnier in an older age uh tequila right
oh okay thanks
so I was like yo let's go oh
hold on hey you still got the tahin on
there okay I haven't had this much tahin
since I uh
we didn't even do the shot well well the
booze is working yeah
the setup was clutch ooh this is great
this
look up automatic Slims it's right
around the corner from uh the other
one's good it's on Greenwich Street yeah
I I've this is a great party bar
I've never been in there when people
were in there it's always automatic
Slims yeah well I've only been there
when it's packed like crazy okay here's
the the Bermuda Triangle of that
neighborhood is wxou yep uh automatic
Slims White Horse Tavern yeah also I go
to another bar for football Sundays it's
the only sports bar in the West Village
logies no that's a Philly bar so I stay
away from it
um is uh
is a barrow
um
if you watch you're a hardcore Patriots
guy I like the Patriots I've kind of
fallen out uh not Barrel we talked about
does your brother still work for the
Dolphins no he's in a new team he's uh
the bear so I'm like man
um
was that dick yeah okay
um yeah
um yeah so like when I want to like
watch a game
you know that's like yeah put in a
Patriots bar yards they are they yards
bayards uh no good Wings over there
bayards I I went to bayard's once and
there is a so you're going to Dublin
yeah so I I'm like friendly with the
bartender there this is a crazy story I
go I I tell the bartender she's from
uh Ireland and I go yeah I'm going to
Dublin Belfast Copenhagen Oslo was one
of the best shows I've ever had in my
life um
what's Oslo I mean give me some
highlights of Oslo I did a sauna on the
water
you can go they have these saunas that
are on the Fjord and you can just go in
there and then jump in the water the
water's like you know freezing cold what
time of year are you going uh September
late September you got to do it you got
to do that is on the water and you can
like it's just it was unbelievable there
um but I'm at bayard's and the woman
she's like it's like three in the
morning she goes you gotta try and talk
about recommendations since we're on the
topic I go I'm going to Belfast she goes
the best pizza in the world's in Belfast
best pizza in the world is in Ireland I
go no way I'm like I'm not
getting I go I'm living in New York
you're not telling me yeah yeah she goes
no no you gotta go get pizza in Belfast
I go what are you talking about I go
look it up what's it called
uh that's where Van Morrison's from
what are the Belfast pizza place just
look it up Splats spats
spats something what's it called
Belfast Pizza
no
this is the Bell slow search right here
[Music]
I guess look at the name for your show
sucking Zagat
it's called what is it called
all right we're gonna get it right here
oh this pizza looks like ass come on
that ain't it uh
uh the Pizza Guys these are great names
Pizza Works
Little Wing Pizzeria Little Italy no
that's not bad looking good Fellas of
course heck greens Pizza yuck Pizza
flout
pizza maybe it's crazy so I go this
woman she's like the best pizza in the
world in in Belfast I go come on why
would I go to Pizza Belfast she goes you
gotta go I messaged this guy on
Instagram flout Pizza I go hey man I'm
holy it looks good I mean this is
like crust I go to I message this guy
I'm like hey I'm gonna be in town on
this he goes he goes we're we're out of
pizza by two can you be here before too
and I'm like this good sign right yeah I
go to this pizza place I get there at
like one and he's like basically put
aside a pizza for me what well how do
you do that what do you what his name is
I get a crazy business plan for this guy
get more pizza right right yeah right
you're running out every day at 2PM his
name's Peter we have a slice together it
was very bored Danish I go hey man he
gives me like a big hug when I walk in
this guy's name is Peter is a big
redheaded guy and I go what's I go I'm
here and he puts out a whole thing for
me and it's like they do the deep dish
they do the you know all the different
types they make their own homemade hot
honey with like the chilies in it oh
come on he's like my wife got diagnosed
with some sort of disease and I've
always just had an interest in Pizza I
went and put all our money into the oven
and I'm open this place wow I was
touched and I'm like it's the best pizza
I have ever we should have saved some
for treatment
hahaha
out of my life it's your number one I
think it's number one wow I think it's
number one Dublin how about that
this guy was the nicest guy and then he
like we we had a moment this is the
thing when someone gives you a good
recommendation and you're like helping
their business and he's like I you know
just like us when someone likes your
comedy you go this is I put everything I
know you know I I can't thank you enough
I don't know what to say there he is
there's Peter Peter that's him on the
right he's like what he's got two kids
wow he's like I gotta leave his wife
okay I don't know I didn't ask I was
afraid to ask I don't know I was gonna
ask he couldn't have been nicer to me
gave me everything for free I like
dropped a 50 on the table I go this is
for the house I don't know what to do so
I mean no offense but I feel like like
if I dm'd a restaurant they'd be like
yeah come in and buy a piece you choo
choo right who do you think you are well
I came in planning in the pay yeah I
dm'd him I go hey man that looks really
good believable and this guy
that's the type of piece I like I like
the thin crust oh easy yeah but it's
crazy to go to a bar when you start to
get to know the so I April 28th at two
times
Belfast next week I'd love to come in
the date is 5'4 he writes back would
love to have you we'll be open do you
want to let me know a time that suits
you we might have a little cue but you
might be right on uh come right on in
and say hello if that's cool so I go 2
30 he's like he's got to pick up his
kids he's telling me all this stuff
it's just I had such like a heartwarming
when someone's like hey go message the
place and go yeah I love it I'm
impressed with you too because somebody
goes hey the best pizza in Belfast I go
all right keep the shots coming
I'll see you later you know I don't
listen she wasn't the only one who told
me that because the first time I did the
same thing I'm like I'm live in New York
I've had the best Pizza by the
way best pizza I've had what is it is
New Haven oh it's pretty good I think
Frank Pepe's Sally's those are some
insanely good and also and also
in Tulsa there's a place he's a New York
guy who makes it in Tulsa uh the DeMarco
slice we plugged them on here before but
it was incredible I mean we've had a lot
of good pizza in our day I love yeah I
love a good slice I get mad when so
again bad recommendation when when I go
somewhere someone's like all the pizza
I'm like get the out of here yeah I
came from New York give me give me the
you know what you do it's angelini's and
uh
in Tulsa okay
I always say and then Colin Quinn backed
me up on this best pizzas in Long Island
and people laugh at me and I go I don't
know it's a great pizza and then Colin
Quinn goes all the Brooklyn guys moved
to Long Island yeah so they just brought
the pizza I'm with you on that I think
like now it's like all those people that
have those like Mom and Pop dinner
restaurant type pizza places yeah I
think Jersey definitely has some place
oh Jersey's got some great pizza yeah
yeah Staten Island still New York City
probably you have to go to Staten Island
right that's no problem there but yeah
they do have great they do have great
pizza I don't leave the island so I'm
like yeah yeah I'm lazy as well
it's amazing you won't go to Staten
Island but you'll go to Belfast for
pizza
but I relate to that yeah it's the
people
yeah
Delta doesn't do Delta one there
I Delta one is clutch yeah oh I'm
I'm going to La I got no Delta one I
didn't either fifth on the list I'm
going later too when are you going I'm
going in a week oh I'll be there in like
later this month again it would have
been fun to double up on some of these
yeah hell yeah are you doing shows there
yeah doing the ace theater and I'm gonna
Jump Around The Improv in the store yeah
I'm doing the Improv on Friday but I I
no that Delta one thing it stares at you
like I know like a hundred thousand
miles and you're like I don't gotta I'm
not doing a hun what no and then you're
like I had the worst one the other day I
missed a flight so they put me on
standby for the next flight and I was
third on standby and they're like hey
okay Jeff Johnson he's number one yes
just number one's going it I feel like
you know I was holding a like a ticket
yeah and then they're like number two
Bob Seger okay Bob said here we go baby
and then they go Joseph wheeler he was
26 and I go what the is that you
jumped me and she was like he's got
status more than you how is that
possible I know so I didn't get on that
bothers me so much we fly so much we
haven't been to an airline and I go who
I need an interview anyone that's ahead
of me I'm like I gotta know everything
about their life yeah right I think who
was it like maybe Todd Barry once said
look you can't beat China like if
someone flies to China once they beat
you like you're but like I just
want to know what their life is I'm
taking United to uh Australia I did that
I don't I don't normally
give me something that will give me some
points right I'm 1K with United because
of Australia
and that's one flight yeah I'm back
there Delta's Delta's solid for they're
all they're all man bad but like United
uh they'll just cancel a flight
with no explanation
Delta they're so out in front of it yeah
like the app is so good I think if you
have a good app great app we we're good
I went to the Delta after the United app
and it was like loading forever I'm like
Jesus Christ pick it up United right
right no it's good to have competition
you want you don't want there to just be
one it's like when Netflix was only
dominating it's like yes you won other
of course it keeps them in check
but yeah you go to the United States
like on a cable you know it's slow hotel
room cable you're like change
the channel yeah with no uh guide button
yeah you're like oh I can't actually go
through the numbers to find ESPN oh yeah
sorry go ahead that's a peeve of mine
the hotel channels there's a
weird black delay between every channel
and I'm like this ads like 25 minutes to
my watching because if you add it all
same exactly we didn't even do
relationship questions did we should we
let's do a couple let's go we got you
here in there let's do it so we Jared
somewhere to go on the first date Jared
is really good at this we've
done both on his podcast and he you give
articulate and insightful advice well
I'm usually not three drinks in that's a
shot but we'll see what happens here now
you get the real advice Let's see we got
my girlfriend and I've been dating for
two years she moved to New York to get
her Masters I stayed here in Baltimore
I cannot leave the state of Maryland
until 2026 the earliest 26th what year
is it now I know high school he's got a
widely graduated while she's committed
to never living in Maryland again good
for her uh and plans on either staying
in New York or moving back with their
parents in Philly after she graduates we
really are in love but I feel like this
past year of long distances created
almost daily fights over the stupidest
can long distance work long
term I mean I I don't think so but no it
can but not in this situation no they're
done it's over she's trying to she's
trying to get the baby to cry himself to
sleep yes she wants this to end and she
doesn't want to end it I can tell you
right now like the idea that you're
having daily fights okay over the
distance when you have long distance you
need the only way long distance work is
a plan so it's like hey this week we're
doing Baltimore next week we're gonna do
if you're in a serious relationship as
they are and they have been in why is
the communication not about what our
solution is it's all about the problems
right the problem is the problem he
can't move until 2026. if you're talking
about the problem that means someone
wants out of it and wants to remind you
there's a problem yeah she's trying to
get you to dump yourself right and
you're the loser you're at home and
stuck in Maryland until 2026. so the
loser it's tough to be the winner and
dump you oh so she doesn't want to dump
you well said good well said I told you
guys
yeah yeah and she's in New York she's at
Mother's ruin right now blowing a
finance guy
a time of her life she's like I gotta
take this he's gonna you know cry about
our relationship yeah and she's hoping
the next call is you going hey it's over
for me but you're never gonna do that
because you're in loser land Maryland
she's in Winterville New York and you're
like well when if you're not talking
about when's the next visit you're only
talking about you know what's making you
not want to visit yes exactly so I hate
to say it I don't want to be mean to the
guy but like get out you gotta get out
of jail free card and go get laid in
Baltimore it's time to end it and I I
feel for them because this is the
hardest thing because you go
we're so good here when we're in
Maryland it's like oh you know you got a
four-year prison sentence yeah Barrel is
over baby yeah yeah long and it's like
it's not even that it's not like you're
doing New York to LA or something you're
doing but it's a pretty easy train ride
but then that but that turns into its
own thing right totally here's the thing
list distance it does work and it
doesn't work you know what those two
opinions take over the conversation like
it can work but you're not even doing
the things to make it work right that
means someone's not trying that means
someone doesn't want to be in this
relationship she thought I think she
probably thought this was the out oh New
York and he's holding on to it right
she's like oh you're still holding on to
it but she doesn't want to break up with
him so they're fighting it's hard when
you love someone to end it of course of
course so the worst relationships are
the ones the worst endings the ones you
blame on something else and you go oh
it's the distance no it's not the
distance you both don't want to be
together yep yeah you're you're saying
the distance is the problem but she
moved she didn't even include you in
that conversation she's not even saying
what's the dates you're coming in yeah
that's poor daily fights I feel bad it
sucks but it's time it does suck all
right well let's ruin another life
here's we got another been with my
girlfriend for almost two years now
she's great the only problem is she's
not as fit as she was when we first met
and I don't find myself as attracted to
her as when we first met the problem say
that yeah I've made that mistake before
oh really yeah I actually said that I
know I up I'm a bad person how'd
you do it yeah I said yeah you've gained
a lot of weight what
that's crazy I have a joke about this in
my act now but how like you can't you
got to make it positive you gotta you
gotta be like I think it's cool that
everyone the ice cream store knows your
name
but I can't believe it I know that's
crazy
so did she
the problem is she seems to have no
desire to go to the gym at all anymore
when should I start worrying that I
won't be physically attracted during the
long term well my opinion is you already
ain't yeah yeah you got to be with
someone who you're attracted to and if
they're not gonna take care of
themselves and you do then that
attraction's a part of a relationship
here's the problem this this
conversation gets bogged down in the
wait wait you know the the physical
physical looks of it it's not about that
you guys have different interests now
you know she is interested in living a
lifestyle that you have a different
interest in that's the really way to
look at it it's not you know attracted
not attracted you're just turned off by
this lifestyle lately again that's not a
judgment of like someone's looks that's
we have different interests right do you
think that's like more of the core of
the issue maybe not interest maybe like
if you want to be with someone who goes
uh should I put on some weight I gotta
work on this right that's the thing my
motivation yeah like listen everyone has
different looks they're into sure so
it's like this isn't about good or bad
this is about my mentality is a little
I'm turned off by the mentality just
like you said like the motivation yeah
it's a big part of it like and I think
when it gets what gets in the way is
like the looks Factor yeah because
that's not what this is about but there
are people out there who are really hot
when they're single and then get into
relationship thing and they're like I'm
letting this I'm letting everything out
I mean that's me I mean I'm farting
everywhere I'm all over the
house I'm like a dog that wasn't trained
you know I'm like I'm out there like I
remember that I was dating a girl and
she was like I started and she was like
it's enough like
oh like I am not attracted this joke
isn't funny anymore I thought I'm like
walking around that's how I proposed
there you go she was like I do but I
here's what's Tough by this and women
they're not going to want to hear this
but women get mad at men for this
like that's so in insensitive and it's
like it's just how we're wired we don't
want to be this way right it's just if a
guy loses his job and goes broke and
just sits on the couch all day playing
video games that's unattractive too
right well that's again but that goes
back to motivation it's not about looks
right it's not about it she's gained
weight it's I'm not attracted to this
version of the person that I used to be
attracted to yes and that's in the way
of it now are there Solutions hey I'm
like if I was this person you want a
solution to your problem here's some
ideas why don't you start doing some
Fitness classes that you want to do that
you would have fun doing an includer um
but is that not kind of like insulting
to her being like hey I want to do this
thing I'm getting into running I'm
getting into this I you know I would
love for you to come with me I don't
know I think I think it's a good idea I
just don't know if it's gonna hurt her
feelings it might but that's what's
tough about the ladies is like now she's
fat and crying you know you're like wait
what you can't have both you know like
so you gain weight and don't say that
okay folks like this is too bad things
yeah it is I think it's more like you
know if it's a motivation thing maybe
you're the you know because obviously
when someone like puts on weight some
sometimes it's like I'm out of my groove
you know maybe they're going through
something else that you don't know you
know like where like hey I'm looking to
do stuff let's do something new maybe
that gets them out of their Funk and you
go and now you're back you know hey
we're doing this class so it's kind of
fun like I'm part of that there's I I
this gets this conversation gets like
shushed by people will be like you're
being rude exactly it's not about let's
change what the conversation's about is
really what I think I like that that's a
good point and it's a good way to get it
off weight a little bit too not about
weight you know like listen I I've been
with women I'm like they put on a few
pounds I'm like yeah and you can go the
other way and get too skinny it goes
always that's true I think that out of
the group thing is like really important
good point yeah are you okay it's like
it's like hey let's let's switch it up
let's go here let's go somewhere else
right and just like it's like you can
tell someone to go to the gym when
you're both at home or whatever and that
just sounds rude or you know like
they're not gonna listen to that they
just it just makes them feel better
that's a hard thing to say to a woman
though too to be like I've noticed
you've gained 25 pounds you must be in a
rut let's talk about it no exactly but
no but if you just say like yo let's
take this trip let's go here let's go
there and change it up yeah
it's lacking like I'm trying to hang out
with you exactly right it's really the
I think that's really important to do
but this guy's in a tough spot he's a
long one oh a woman I'm married I'm
married 10 years dating and on
the regular for at least the first eight
years and then things slowly started to
dwindle I think they were oh
they were on the regular and
then things started doing okay I mean
eight years is pretty good I the female
was always being the one who instigate
and over time I would get the I'm tired
then it came down to rejection
like I'm tired or you're too drunk
that's when I started giving up I'm
super horny and I just turned 40. and I
feel like I'm in my Prime this is
reading like a penthouse yeah I found my
chub move I'm so ready to it any
moment
I asked my husband if he doesn't want to
me maybe we could have an open
relationship no maybe we could swing no
so I got a couple vibrators and they're
awesome but I'm feeling the urge to
cheat because I'm so unhappy and so
horny what do you think wow I mean this
was a pretty hot message
forums type stuff
um these are the women when you're
single and you meet that gal at the bar
and like can I buy you a drink she's
like you can buy me a cab you're like
it's my lucky day you know but you gotta
find these women they have to go through
hell before they do that to you uh I
mean this person needs to end their
marriage it sounds like I mean that's I
mean there's only one piece of advice
there's a reason again it's not the sex
it's not the problem it's the other
problem you know like there there's a
reason this person's not having sex and
it's not about their Tire
yeah about the oh no if they're straight
up turning you down you're not having a
conversation if you can't be only
talking about sex you're right why are
you turning me down I'm looking uh what
when do you feel turned on by me when it
when why what what's the disconnect here
I don't think they're talking you're
right yeah you're right and there's
something in the relationship that's in
the air there's a stale thing going on
that he's bottling up and that's what's
preventing him from this is a
very male way of arguing too of like of
like kind of shutting off as like he's
either lost interest in the relationship
or he's around he's
around oh because he's always turning
down sex I mean like I don't buy that a
guy has zero sex drive I understand
right that sex slows down in every
relationship but to have zero drive and
never want to your partner or again
we go to the body stuff maybe he's going
through something you know what are you
going through like this is they've made
it about sex and it's not about sex at
all you know like I oh my husband won't
me what should I do I'm thinking of
cheating no no let's take care of the
husband issue right this isn't the sex
issue this is a marriage issue and she's
getting hammered and he's not basically
she's saying like I get really he's like
you're too drunk so she's out getting
hammered and he's at home probably
working or watching TV so they're
already disconnecting there so there's a
lot of stuff going on in this
relationship that she's not saying yeah
there's it's
again the answer sometimes in the email
yeah maybe like they've got to do a date
night thing where they get drunk
together I mean they got to try
something well that's the thing here's
the thing relationships are negotiations
you have to have two people at the table
having the negotiation she's negotiating
negotiating against herself
like he's hey I want to have sex no
that's not a negotiation right that's
nothing okay she's gotta follow-up well
why
what's going on and sex becomes hard
because you're like I don't want to
force someone to have sex with me that's
not what you're asking about you the sex
is done we're not having sex I don't
even know why you're not having sex
exactly they're they're bottling stuff
up and
she's trying to just and forget
about it and he's like I can't you
I got stuff in my head that's the thing
she's like this email is written to be
cool girl right you know like there's a
lot of like I want to everybody
yeah I got the vibrators
they like uh and then I'll put them away
we have to go to a therapist they don't
even they need a big fight a big
fight would save this and nobody wants
to have that fight because it's
confrontation it's awkward but that
would clear the air and then they would
right after I guarantee it or he's
cheating or he's cheating it sounds like
he might be cheating it does sound like
guys who like once they feel they slip
the ring on they're like I don't know if
she's here forever now I don't have to
try ever yeah there's there like if I
was that way though I'd be depressed
like if I was in a marriage where I'm
like bring on no more I'd be
like what are we what I know I always
hear that from like reality yeah it's a
women thing right now you hear that from
like married people oh and it's like a
joke I'm like that's not a joke that's
prison yeah you gotta lock the guy down
so now you can be a shitty person right
you've got yourself out of the game
right I have a friend I remember I was
at his place we were all hanging out and
it's like a college buddy he's got kids
he's like and he had this like he was
kind of hammered but he gave this like
big speeches like if we're okay they're
okay he kept being like if we're okay
husband and wife the kids are okay and I
always was like yeah I think he's got a
good point yeah you know like I'm like
if my mom and dad are still I'll
probably be happier than if they're not
that's a great point and maybe
this could be a bit right there's
something there's something there
something there I think so throw that in
I got for the bit sex I like it I like
it all right we got another one here I'm
curious if you guys feel stand up and
proves or hinders your game with women
forget about it right I don't think you
should get in a stand-up solely to
pursue dating absolutely not but uh I'm
curious to hear if you think it benefits
your social life in that area thanks
comedy comedy this is someone who
already got into stand up to
like hey this should be going better
than I've
not in a comedy by the way I mean it
makes it easier to meet women obviously
than after shows or in the DMS or
whatever but I think you know uh you're
in you get less I mean Jared and I were
talking about you know going out earlier
like we definitely you know all of us
would hit the town and stuff but that's
after shows you get a late start you
miss out on a lot of the socializing I
think well here's the thing about stand
up you're just in more social areas yeah
than you would be if you didn't do
stand-up like you know Monday night you
wouldn't be out if you didn't do stand
up you'd be at home watching your shows
so it's like it's like the apps oh I you
know people like I hate the apps and
you're like yeah because it's more it's
just more you know like so for stand up
we're just out more and it's on
someone's big night so like yeah you're
gonna meet more people I don't think
you're gonna meet more like
I I I've never I don't think I've met
more like
Partners like that I was like crazy
about because of you know like I I guess
I'm out I don't know like and you're
talking to a big group and then you go
out after and you have a good answer
well what do you do Jared I'm a comic
what holy what's that like so now
you're in it you know it's not like I'm
a I'm a you know data entry guy oh nice
to meet you there all right
what's this guy do you know you're
you're in it and you're funnier you have
lines you have quips you know yourself
you can read a room you can read a woman
that is the thing you do pick up skills
to be able to talk to anybody like when
I'm like okay I can go into performance
mode at any point yeah exactly so you
got like when you you ever been in a bar
in like some some woman's like kind of
like being being mean and just trying to
give you negging and they're a
little nagging and then you go uh okay
now I gotta go on to like you know you
gotta go to the sheath and start doing
my crowd work yeah and you kind of go
into that and they're like what what the
is that they were a ninja yeah it's
like yeah there's a little of that that
comes in handy but it's not that person
that's trying to nag me isn't
my like the partner I'm looking at no
you know I know maybe that night but no
not a partner yeah uh all right good one
is it strange for 28 year old women to
sleep with a stuffed animal do you want
to see this you ever see this where you
go to someone's house and they got like
the blankie from there yeah I don't love
it here's what I don't love
it's not that I don't care about the
stuffed animal the blankie it's when
it's disgusting uh you ever see when
it's like they've chewed on it for a
thousand years and you're like yeah I
wouldn't I don't care it's from your
childhood it's just we're sleeping with
a mop
yeah it is like off color it's not about
what it is I don't give a if you
have you know the snuggle bear from the
commercial it's if it has literally
dried on it I don't want that
another dude is a dry and cement
yeah it's crunching sleeping yeah I know
I'm with I don't I don't love the stuff
that it's a little kitty and weird I
don't know you got some trauma some past
stuff coming up I don't it's a little
much
I guess I've seen like a weird blankie
or stuff but right well if you kids
you're gonna see a lot of this it'll
come up quite a bit a pacifier diapers
whatever it is this was sent to us by a
priest yeah and uh
how do you get better at fighting we are
similar in the sense of knowing each
other so well that our fights can get
too hurtful and mean we both know we
need to control our own anger and fight
better but doing it is hard in the
moment how can we get better at that oh
that's tough you don't want to pull out
hey you hey your mom's a like
you don't want to go that yeah you fat
like that's when it gets up it's
hard when one of you is calm and the
other one is is like that's true because
sometimes it's uneven where one person
is a terrible communicator and the other
person is very peaceful right and then
you're the peaceful one is kind of like
a little resentful like well I didn't
take any low blows yes I could
have right I didn't I that that's to me
like the worst type of relationship I
hate it it's trashy it's trash it is to
be like you know because it to me from
the email it sounds like two people who
like winning
and it's like if you want to win you're
like we've all been on stage and had a
Heckler or someone that's been shitty
and you're like I'm just gonna say the
most horrific thing to this person it
never works and it never works it's a
great uh Instagram video a comedian
destroys girlfriend
destroys comedian oh he's like you're
not funny and they're like you see the
comedian die like I hate that one bit
you do your clothes just stinks
[Laughter]
but I've had that thing where you're on
stage and you're like
I I like and then you don't feel good
afterwards like that's why this person's
asking this question like they get out
of that fight and they're like oh we're
both
Rocky and Apollo at the end of the fight
like we're both battered by this like
yeah argument that made us both realize
that we both like said the worst things
we could ever I don't know like and the
worst part is you will never forget that
Zing that she that crazy barn burner of
a line she had on you that's gonna live
in your head forever even when you're
doing well is in a relationship right
kind of I yeah no one's likable I
had someone at Stanford I was in
Stanford I did the uh the new New York
comedy club there oh yeah it was pretty
good I had pretty good
um not pretty good actually really good
yeah I had a great weekend
um but one of the people in the crowd
the last show
there was a woman with her boyfriend
they were just talking like you could
tell they weren't there for my show
which is fine
um but it's like they were just having a
conversation and then I got to a part of
my bit and they were like uh the one I
said something about like yeah before
the beach you like look at yourself in
the mirror and she's like not and I'm
like I'm talking about like looking at
your body in the mirror for the beach
she's like nah if you wear a tankini and
I go
okay I look at I go
um I I made I was like oh let me see if
the rest of the room wants to hear the
the drunk rantings of a of a a horrible
woman and I like look at the crap and
like they all laughed and I was like
okay we're done like yeah I got you done
and then she's like
she kept doing this with her hand like
to yell at the stage and she's like no
you don't you know you know oh no one
wears a tankini I go I don't know what
you're talking about your fashion sense
is old yeah
like it's been done we're having and
every time I got her she'd come back
with something else and I'm like I don't
want to do this it's only and then it
kept evolving into me you know like yeah
because there's a point where it's like
yelled out I got you gotcha like it's
over it's over we can get out of this
and then uh she yelled then she goes he
tried to get tickets for Matt Rife and
we couldn't get him
and I was like I go okay I go I go I
guess you're gonna have to blow him
behind his back another time
and that's not that mean not that mean
but I didn't feel good about it like I
was just like I can't enough of it
because her thing got like a reaction
like the matte right which I honestly I
I you seem like the type that would go
to that yeah enjoy it like go have fun
and good for Matt like I but it isn't
one of those things that like the whole
I'm like no they should go to that show
I'd be happy you know like but it is
funny that like when it got to that
point I was just like yes I got you
again I when does this end Mia please
stop or count security step in what are
we doing here but I I hate to me talking
is worse than heckling I would rather be
heck because I can give a back and forth
but just
I'd rather be hated than apathy's worse
than right yeah right yeah exactly that
was the thing that's why I called them
out because they were talking for the
first like three minutes and then she
yells out like three and a half minutes
and I'm like okay now I can let you know
how I feel like I now have an idea yes
where the crowd's gonna know that like
you should be gotten and then when you
don't give that up and I I bring this
back to this email because
when you're just going back and forth at
different vulnerable barbs
you know like there's nothing to be won
there's it's just an implosion like so I
don't know you know this is horrific
yeah yeah that's a that's a problem quit
drinking ladies all right I recently
left my girl because I didn't think she
has the curves I wanted he should meet
up with the fat chick absolutely great
rearrange the couple yeah with a stellar
personality of course he's got a great
personality she's huge but I just didn't
I couldn't see hitting it from behind
for eternity that's hilarious gentlemen
you've got a bunch of knights and
shining armor writing him let me know
should I lower my standards or stay
strong and hold out for the right cheeks
who wrote this Vanilla Ice
[Laughter]
person is horrific I should have the
right curves I wanted
what is wait let me know should I lower
my standards or stay strong I think you
should be attracted to the person you
want to be with but also this sounds
like it sounds a a little shallow here I
don't know a little yeah yeah hitting
from behind for eternity is that
Hallmark
um yeah I don't know this breakup speech
is going to be rough right yeah baby
girl you know I love hitting that
backside but not for not lately
but what happens when age kicks in right
yeah piece of I don't know this guy
go seek a therapist yeah I don't know
either all right number one how do you
approach the talk about budgets I can't
believe you got both of those emails in
the same we got a range of listeners
yeah what a range
hey the next email is gonna be when you
tapping that ass
if you have a child from a previous
relationship how do you introduce them
to your to you so these are the
questions they thought of for you guys
they were like
it's mean I mean maybe money in a
relationship yeah
okay well I I don't know what the
budgets are for I think they need to get
more specific yeah hey how do you feel
about rent on a monthly basis what do
you you know I think how do you feel
questions are always good
um if you have a child from a previous
relationship how do you introduce them
to your child I think you gotta be okay
with not introducing people to your kid
huh like I think you got to be like
so people have to deserve that meeting
well but these are both his kids I think
yeah I'm just saying like
I don't think like nothing his two kids
should meet each other you mean if you
have a chat oh you know oh if they both
have I thought he was introducing them
to their this might be a woman they're
dating or Shake oh yeah whoever
Chapman River later how do you introduce
them to your children yeah them I think
is
the person they're dating oh yeah yeah
so I think they're good yeah they're
going how do I and it's like okay I
would make sure that they deserve to
like your kid's a big deal you're gonna
have to yeah you're gonna have to undo
that maybe so like I wouldn't want to
wait a while right let that happen you
know talk about your kid you know
you know be proud of them but like
you know I would I would uh do that
early you would do it early yeah just to
let them know because you don't want to
have a great relationship then you go
hey by the way uh well Timmy here has
got down syndrome and they're like wait
what I didn't know you had a kid and now
I have the kid I'm saying like introduce
them oh okay okay well when you hear the
uh the screaming from the anal out of
the bedroom I think uh the kid will get
a hip to it he's gonna come in there
going mommy are you is there a woman
getting hurt in here you know so uh
that's a tough one
ah jeez why do I have a hard time
trusting my girlfriend has ever given me
reason to doubter but I always assume
she's out to do the worst I believe
she's either cheating or flirting with
the next best looking guy I've never
been cheated on so it's not past drama I
don't know what it is perhaps I'm super
insecure if so what the hell do I do
about it this is a tough type of guy to
date if you're a woman the guy if she's
out with her friends and he's like where
the were you you yeah Chuck E
cheese it's with my mom
we're at Mount Sinai
we're talking about the you know Tom
skandival you know like
we had a we had a Bravo Meetup oh maybe
he is sensing something well perhaps
some insecure you're insecure he is like
let's just let's just admit whether it's
brought upon by this relationship or
yeah you are not secure you're not
secured so like let's uh let's let's
Zone in on the prop the problem isn't
your girlfriend it is you it is time to
seek therapy you're insecure let's take
stock of the things you're good at like
let's start working on my you know
security I'm insecure we're all insecure
we all have our things big time I think
you gotta like
accept it yeah that's a you know that's
the first thing you got to do but also
see you know a little bit of treat
because this is only gonna Fester he's
just gonna get more and more and he's
gonna start checking her phone he's
gonna there's nothing more unattractive
than jealousy
it's not great it's a bad it's not a
good feeling especially when she hasn't
done anything yet like if she cheated at
one point I get it okay but this guy is
pulling out of thin air well yeah
we don't know like maybe there may has
she given him reasons to feel this way
we don't know his past relationships his
history he goes why do I have a hard
time trusting which makes me think this
is not a new thing he says he's never
been cheated on yeah I I I you know
I trust his email perhaps I'm super
insecure no yes you know it you've
opened it out you wrote it yeah you
wrote to strangers right this was your
you know this is an admission so can he
bring this up to her or is that weird to
be like look I'm just nuts you know you
everything all right out there we good
yeah you wouldn't cheat on me I don't
know when does a partner ever fix your
problem
hmm so you got to fix yourself before
you can like fix yourself with the price
or be aware enough to what your faults
are right like I was all you know the
nighttime eating stuff I'm like I know
that's something I do I know that's
something I don't want to do as much
okay acknowledging it is like okay the
first step is can I be with someone who
hey you might see me get drunk and be
like I need to eat I'm sorry
about that like this is something I'm
working on yeah you know
right right I don't know what to do to
fix it but he should realize yeah I am
insecure and it could get ugly like you
don't want to just start yelling at her
one night so you got to deal with
yourself you're right
in a relationship with a woman who won't
have sex uh oh the old flipperoo again
her sex drive is not what it used to be
I try to look past it because she is a
great woman and would make a great wife
But the Sex is not there and it's
starting to get to me how do I know
where to draw the line I'm trying to put
her needs before mine but mine aren't
being met and it's starting to affect me
should I leave am I an for
leaving her if we don't no you're
not no you're not it's time to leave
this yeah I mean I don't I don't
understand why I mean I would ask her
why she's not you yeah right I I
hate that line of like she's a great
woman would make a great what it was but
you're not happy at you yeah exactly if
you're not you're saying your needs
aren't being met so why are you a bad
person for leaving these are your needs
and it's also like you pull aside and
you're like hey you notice that you
never me yeah what's going on here
yeah most people think it's not the
it's the relationship yeah yeah
so it's like that's the headline they're
burying the lead yeah you guys are not a
great couple I and people do this a lot
you know they go They're a good person
they're you know they check all these
boxes anyone would like them yeah anyone
would like anything Mother Teresa was a
great woman right do I want to stick it
inside her well she let me stick it
inside her do it for the story
yeah yeah I think you gotta either talk
to her or get out there you're young
you're fun
everyone's great to someone you know I I
think like and I know that's hard easier
advice to give them to take but when you
write she's a great woman and would make
a great wife what about the things
specific to your relationship those are
just vague yeah you want this to be your
wife and never get laid again
bad idea this sounds like you gotta get
out of this yeah it's okay two good
people can break up yeah for sure and
I've and I work by myself with that in
every break two you can be a you can end
the relationship and also be an okay
person this is the best person to break
up with because you know she's not
the next guy
you're not stressed like oh my God she's
probably right some guy's probably balls
deep in her probably not maybe she
doesn't like sex yeah some people aren't
maybe you know maybe it's just not you
maybe I mean these are the ones I wonder
like was the sex ever because I've been
in those before where like the sex isn't
great out of the gate and you're like I
can't maybe we'll figure it out maybe we
won't but you know there are people who
just don't have high sex drives and it
ain't getting better but also you again
this goes back to relationships in our
negotiation like it's like you're not
negotiating they have they're not at the
table with you right yeah so it's like
okay we need to be at the table about
something else obviously right oh yeah
something's up and who knows how long
they've been together hopefully if it's
not long he can still get out I gotta
say this Margarita it's good it hit me
it's too good I'm like trying to slow
down but I think we gotta wrap up he
he's got a this kid like crazy
has a new special uh I'm probably not uh
do it because I do it he's doing it
alone you want the shot no I'm not I'm
out you guys for yeah well we've been
doing this is our second spot and I got
day drunk yesterday I got drunk last
night I gotta wake up for a flight okay
I'll do it with you hey you got shows
Jared
it's 37 in singles yeah baby it's on
Netflix do you get on Netflix any dates
you want to play graders great website
there that is a good photo oh I just
took a whole shoot with uh Provincia hey
we love Phil been a while great guy hey
it's beginning
Colchester I I know Colchester I'm doing
the vineyard show I'm doing a a labor
day whatever wine whatever
uh get some good wine uh Providence
Atlanta Huntington
yeah just watch the special I want
people to go enjoy it it's 37 and single
dating breakups late night eating
Jews I talk about you I got a nice Jew
section nice nice
uh what else uh you got your podcast my
podcast the J train but you guys have
both been great guests on that show oh
thank you this fun time and mark You're
Gonna oh yeah I'm coming back awesome
um and then yeah another special 37th
thing I want everyone to go watch and
enjoy it was a fun gender reveal bit all
right so hell yeah all right check out
Jared I can't wait to watch it
and where'd you shoot it again grammar
Street Theater oh Sean December there's
a fun little thing at the end okay I got
something in the credits I know what it
is you show me this watch to the end
yeah Easter egg hey I'm in Springfield
Chesterfield Lisbon big Oslo baby camera
what are you doing Springfield uh I have
no I have some little theater if you go
left there great Hotel
I know the chef at that restaurant get
out of here good guy okay you gotta go
to that it's a great Hotel you're like
why is this hotel here really ended up
there with Anthony DeVito had had a few
Paper Planes
all right yeah and you're gonna love
Oslo I can't wait I'm gonna tell people
I know you I know in uh Belfast you
gotta sit pop into Belfast apparently
how far is that from Dublin not close no
all right ship us a pie there
William Peter Peter Peter pizza man I'm
all over the UK all over London Glasgow
Hershey PA DC Oklahoma City Dallas
Portland Maine Providence Rhode Island
Cleveland Ohio Grand Rapids Michigan
different Colorado Grand Junction New
Orleans Santa Rosa Sacramento Kansas
City Baltimore
super nuts give it a watch get some
Bodega cab where are you at Sammy the
bull York Bethlehem uh we got Toronto
it's a biggie Chicago Theater biggie
Phoenix uh stand up alive can't wait
Pittsburgh Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati
Indy theater at MSG New York November
4th that's the biggie we got Australia
coming we got Florida Tampa Naples uh
we're gonna add a Vegas I think and uh
look out for a special tape in probably
in Boston early next year and uh yeah
we got uh we got Bodega cat whiskey
at Bodega catwhiskey.com look out for
the beer juice book coming out we're
gonna get on that forward you got that
right baby foreskin can't wait and uh
great app man a lot of great wrecks yes
uh I hope people like the
recommendations it's I think it's huge I
think this is the language listen if
you're gonna love it plan a trip to
these places like that's the thing we go
out and we enjoy you know yeah we live
I'm going to Del Rey I
can't wait don't worry it's great all
right thanks for listening guys watch
Jared's special 37 and single on Netflix
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
and make it
it's in dangerous
[Music]